Hallo und äh herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Pritla und äh ja, nach einer weiteren kurzen Pause.
Melden wir uns hier wieder mit äh UKW Corona äh Wickli, mit mir und mit äh Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Genau, hallo, äh alles nicht so ganz so äh Wiki, wie wie bisher. Wir hatten jetzt die letzte Sendung am 10. August. Heute ist der 31. August, das heißt, wir haben jetzt mal wieder drei Wochen verstreichen lassen. Immer so ein bisschen in der Hoffnung, dass sich irgendwas Nennenswertes ändert.
Und dass wir äh neue Erkenntnisse liefern können. Jetzt ist es halt so ein noch ein bisschen so gewesen, dass wir andere Dinge äh zu tun hatten, aber auch so neue Trends äh noch sich noch nicht so richtig
zeichneten, aber heute wollen wir mal zusammenkommen und äh wieder mal ein bisschen versuchen, einzuordnen, was eigentlich bisher so passiert ist und natürlich auch die Diskussion aufgreifen
was denn ähm jetzt passieren sollte, damit nicht mehr so viel passiert. So würde ich das mal formulieren. Ja, Pavel, oder?
Ja. So kann man das äh sagen, ja. Wir sind halt,
jetzt in einer neuen Phase könnte man sagen, fast eingetreten, wo auch wieder erstmal, ja, neue Regeln äh sich rauskristallisieren müssen, die.
Angemessen sind und das passiert jetzt gerade. Also gerade heute hm,
War ja auch so hatten wir überhaupt das Datum schon genannt.
31. August, ich hab's gerade gesagt.
Heute sozusagen am einunddreißigsten äh kam ja dann auch noch,
Nachricht jetzt offiziell, dass man sich äh von der Inzidenz äh verabschiedet als wichtigsten Wert äh für irgendwelche politischen Maßnahmen.
Bundeskabinett beschließt Abkehr von Inzidenz als wichtigsten Corona-Messwert. So so, was ist denn dann der Wichtigste?
Na ja, jetzt will man irgendwie noch die Hospitalisierungsrate.
Äh von Covid-19 Erkrankten äh soll maßgebend sein,
so sagen Regierungskreise und ähm so und Spahn wird zitiert,
bei hoher Impfquote wird die Inzidenz nicht überflüssig, aber sie verliert an Aussagekraft. Ähm,
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie wirklich an Aussagekraft äh verliert, sondern man muss sie halt natürlich nur anders,
interpretieren äh äh dann.
Ja auch meinen, ja und Aussagekraft hat sie meiner Auffassung nach sehr wohl noch. Mhm.
Ist nicht überflüssig, aber
es ist halt als ja als einziger Wert tatsächlich nicht sinnvoll und war es auch noch nie, insofern hat sich da sagen, jetzt auch nicht wirklich viel äh geändert, werden's während des Frühjahr eher die Inzidenz,
Altersgruppen war, die letztlich relevant war, ist es jetzt die Inzidenz in Altersgruppen,
und äh geimpft
Ungeimpft, so das würde ich äh sagen, ist jetzt einfach nur dazu gekommen so. Und ähm ja
dementsprechend muss man halt gucken, äh wie die Impfungen dann jetzt in den Altersgruppen dazu.
Dass die Hospitalisierungsraten entsprechend niedriger sind so und.
Zahlen mal hätte, ne? Kommen wir nachher noch zu zu den äh Impfzahlen, aber das äh fehlt problematisch, ne? Also gut, was er eigentlich sagt
ist, die Inzidenz in den Medien und in der öffentlichen Debatte sollte nicht mehr der einzige Wert sein, weil das ist so im Wesentlichen der einzige, der überhaupt reflektiert wurde und äh auf den äh noch so halbwegs reagiert wurde, wenn man gesagt hat, aber hier die Inzedenz ist ja hoch, dann musste man sich dazu entsprechend äußern
sich wie wir die Sache immer ein bisschen genauer angeschaut hat, weiß äh es ist halt nicht nur die Inzidenz, es ist halt genauso auch der R-Wert, ja, also äh,
der hat sehr viel mehr ausgesagt. Wir waren schon bei denselben Inzidenzwerten mal mehr, mal weniger alarmiert, je nachdem, wohin äh das Pendel denn jetzt eilig geradeaus schlug.
Von daher ist es eben nicht alleine die Inzidenz. Es ist halt der Verlauf der Inzidenz, der äh eine Rolle gespielt hat oder vor allem eine Rolle gespielt hat. Und ich würde ja zustimmen.
Dass es äh unangemessen ist, jetzt nur diesen einzelnen Wert ähm heranzuziehen, weil das schon immer so war,
möglichst viele Werte eigentlich heranzieht, andererseits ist jetzt Hospitalisierung alleine meiner Meinung nach auch nicht unbedingt ausreichend als Kriterium, insbesondere in Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass ähm ja Kinder.
Jetzt haben betroffensten sind. Das wird, werden wir ja gleich aus den Zahlen auch nochmal herauslesen äh äh können. Aber jetzt unbedingt jetzt.
Nicht alles, was ein Problem ist, findet im Krankenhaus statt.
Das ist äh auch das Ding. Und eins, was auch ganz gerne vergessen wird, ist, äh, dass ja, hm, ja, äh, zum Beispiel, Quarantäne trotzdem einhergeht, äh, bei.
Infektion. Äh und äh das führt natürlich dazu, wenn wir plötzlich.
Gewaltige Inzidenzen äh haben, dass unglaublich viele Leute dann in Quarantäne äh sitzen äh werden, auch oder alleine nur.
Ähm aufgrund der Erkrankung erstmal ausfallen. Entweder äh im Beruf, im,
oder eben nicht am Schulunterricht teilnehmen können. Also das ist sagen natürlich auch einen Kostenfaktor. Ich meine, 14 Tage Arbeitsausfall ist halt äh ja
weiß nicht, 150 Euro oder so pro brutto äh äh Arbeitsstunde,
an, an ähm Wertverlust oder Produktivitätsverlust. Äh ja, das ist halt auch teuer.
Von und anderen Spätschäden eben mal gar nicht gar nicht abgesehen. Selbst wenn alles optimal läuft, so heißt äh die Inzidenz diese Leute und ihre Kontaktpersonen äh sitzen gerade zu Hause und.
Können nichts tun. Plus, was auch noch ähm,
als Problem aufgetreten ist jetzt Leute, die,
halt mit bestimmten öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln, also Flieger oder Busse oder bestimmte Bahnen äh bestimmte Fernbahnen in den Urlaub gefahren sind, äh wo,
erfordernis war, dass sie sich halt für die Rückfahrt frei testen lassen
ähm ja, haben sich halt äh zunehmend Fälle jetzt gefunden von Leuten, die dann einfach im Urlaub sich infiziert haben und dann nicht mit ihrem Verkehrsmittel zurückfahren, sondern erstmal dann nochmal im Urlaubsort
auf eigene Kosten irgendwo in einem Quarantänehotel äh untergebracht äh werden. Das erkenne ich irgendwie
ja persönlich äh äh Fälle äh oder zumindest Leute, deren Freunde äh grade davon betroffen sind und in Zagreb gerade im Quarantänehotel äh sitzen.
Ja und nicht zurückkommen. Das ist halt auch noch so ein Ding.
Ja, äh abgesehen von den Zahlen, äh also bleiben wir nochmal ganz kurz noch bei dieser Meldung. Äh ich habe jetzt gerade nochmal ein bisschen weiter äh verfolgt und ähm unter anderem ist auch davon die Rede, dass jetzt teilweise die Maskenpflicht dann auch.
Aufgehoben werden soll im äh äh im Handel ist das richtig äh sehr.
Warte mal, Masken schlägt, eine Sperrstunde, Gastronomie, sollen alles entfalten. Ja gut, äh.
Dafür sehe ich halt die Basis nur so beschränkt, naja.
Ja, also.
Man, ja, jetzt läuft's aber mehr oder weniger jetzt drauf hinaus, äh wie's aussieht, dass jeder sich halt äh selbst zu schützen.
Hat. Äh das scheint mir jetzt so der Übergang äh zu sein. Gerade in die Phase. Und
Ist vielleicht ein bisschen früh äh äh noch noch äh im Moment dafür. Alles laufen zu lassen, aber äh ja. Das ist früher oder später passieren wird und auch passieren sollte, ist
natürlich auch klar.
Da spricht ja auch einiges dafür. Ich würde vorschlagen, wir schauen uns mal so die aktuellen Zahlen an, dass wir mal die Basis äh haben, um dann auch genau diese Frage nochmal zu erläutern.
Ja. Ja, also ich
finde halt vor allem die erstmal die deutschlandweiten Inzidenzen nach Altersgruppen
ganz interessant und was sich dort sowohl deutschlandweit als auch in NRW äh abzeichnet ist, dass die Altersgruppe fünf bis 4zehn
Doch äh ja äh sehr hohe äh Inzidenzen hat so mit
dann äh die die höchsten
interessanterweise bei den ganz kleinen null bis vier äh hält sich das bisher noch in Grenzen, obwohl die auch nicht nicht geimpft sind und äh ja, also bei bei fünf bis vierzehn
eine Inzidenz von 166 Grad.
Tausend in sieben Tagen deutschlandweit, ja. Und äh ja und 134 dann bei den 15 bis Vierunddreißig-jährigen und,
ja die die ältesten also
60 plus, liegt irgendwo bei 17 Energien. Was halt schon ein deutlicher Indikator dafür ist, auch jetzt, dass die,
auch definitiv die Inzidenzen unten halten.
Ja, das ist äh glaube ich äh lässt sich an denen den Zahlen ganz gut ähm.
Lesen, also man kann fast sagen mit gewissen.
Einschränkungen, aber das, ja, einfach, je kleiner die Impfquote in einer Altersgruppe, umso höher.
Die Inzidenz. Und in Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Ist es halt ganz krass, finde ich, da äh haben gerade die Fünf- bis Vierzehnjährigen.
Eine äh Inzidenz von über dreihundertfünfzig, also gerade liegt's bei dreihundertsechzig, war schon bei dreihundertsiebzig in der Altersgruppe fünf bis vierzehn.
Während dort die, ja, sechzig plus so um die dreißig liegen.
Bei der Inzidenz, also zehnmal so hohe äh Inzidenz, kann man sagen, bei Kindern äh wie bei Alten gerade in Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Und die anderen Altersgruppen liegen dann halt so da dazwischen, wie man auch die
fünfzehn bis vierunddreißigjährigen mit fast zweihundert sind auch gut mit dabei. Hundertsiebenundneunzig grade. Ja.
Vielleicht jetzt hast du bisher schon gleich auf diese Altersverteilung eingegangen. Ich würde.
Vielleicht nochmal kurz einen Schritt zurück machen und mir mal so die ganze gesamte Inzidenz, den ganzen Verlauf anschauen und auch mal so auf die Frage eingehen, ist denn das jetzt quasi eine vierte Welle, die wir da jetzt gerade sehen oder verdient äh das Geschehen, diesen Namen derzeit nicht. Also es ging ja
Prinzip, nachdem wir so unseren Tiefpunkt erreicht hatten ungefähr
um den na, was ist das hier so Anfang Juli herum, ja? Darum waren wir so ungefähr bei fünf.
Mit der Gesamtinzidenz, das war ja so quasi das das Luftholen und danach ging's halt wieder äh geschmeidig nach oben. Und wir hatten das ja auch in der letzten Sendung schon,
angesprochen, dass so dass das Tal,
was wir da so durchschreiten im Vergleich zu dem Tal, was wir im letzten Sommer durchschritten haben, ja, sehr viel, sehr viel enger äh gestaltet war, sprich es ging halt sehr, äh die Pause war einfach sehr viel kürzer,
und dann ging's eben auch wieder fleißig nach oben. Und ich denke zum aktuellen
Zeitpunkt lässt sich noch gar nicht so richtig beantworten, also zumindest kann ich mir das jetzt gerade aus diesen Grafiken nicht so richtig beantworten, wo wir denn jetzt eigentlich gerade hinzielen, aber der R-Wert selber wiederum
1,25 ungefähr geschafft hat ist jetzt ja wieder gefallen das heißt das Infektions
geschehen, verlangsamt sich zumindest, naja, in einem bestimmten Maß,
äh das muss jetzt nicht nachhaltig sein, aber das ist jetzt zumindest der aktuelle Fall. Jetzt sind wir so bei 1,1 sechs sehe ich das richtig.
Was ja immer noch nicht schön ist, aber jetzt auch nicht unbedingt darauf.
Hinweist, dass wir jetzt so einen exorbitanten Ausbruch haben. Vielleicht mit der Ausnahme und jetzt kommen wir wieder zurück zu den Altersgruppen, dass man sagen kann.
Die Pandemie findet jetzt einfach nur noch bei den Jüngeren statt.
Ja, ja. Also nur noch bei den.
Jüngeren äh würde ich nicht nicht sagen in allen Altersgruppen äh sind die R Werte dann doch für sich,
genommen, durchaus fast alle auch positiv, aber äh ja. Ähm äh was die Inzidenzen,
angeht auf auf jeden Fall. Aber es bereitet aber es breitet sich schon geringfügig in allen Altersgruppen aus.
So bisher noch. Ja und ähm was wird's aber auch gesehen haben in den letzten beiden Tagen ähm,
ja, einen leichten Rückgang bei der sieben Tage Inzidenz. Unklar, ob das jetzt nur so ein kleiner Hakler ist äh oder wir tatsächlich jetzt schon die.
Ja äh die die Spitze äh erreicht haben von einer neuen Welle und äh ja, ich würde sagen, es ist schon ganz klar die vierte.
So erste, zweite, dritte, vierte Jahr, das ist definitiv eine vierte Welle grade, die hier läuft.
Und so grob als Richtwert nur für die für die Inzidenzen ähm.
Wenn man die jetzt vergleichen will mit mehr Inzidensten als noch niemand geimpft war oder kaum jemand geimpft war,
kann man so übern Daumen eigentlich einen einen Faktor von fünf. Eventuell äh wird sich der, also bei bestimmten Altersgruppen, kann man sogar Faktor zehn
ansetzen. Ähm wo Inzidenz, wenn wir halt, ja, jetzt, ich sage mal, im
Februar, weiß ich nicht, bei sechzig waren oder so. Ähm und im März war mir auch da, wo wo wir wo wir jetzt ungefähr sind bei bei bei siebzig,
kann man das auf jeden Fall eigentlich durch fünf Teilen im Moment die die Inzidenz um so ja auf die Vergleich
Also die resultierende Hospitalisierung äh ungefähr. Ähm.
Daraus zu zu schließen. Sprich, wir können uns jetzt fünf bis zehnmal so hohe Inzidenzen leisten in Anführungszeichen, äh wie jetzt noch vor einem halben Jahr.
Um auf dieselbe Todesrate zu.
Der Impfung, um auf dieselbe, ja, Auslastung des Gesundheitssystems und Todesrate und so, also um sagen, äh ja, die die schlimmen, die schlimmsten Auswirkungen ähm.
Werden halt durch die Impfung so um Faktor 5 bis zehn reduziert.
Dann sag uns doch nochmal kurz äh was zu den Positiv-Quoten und so, dann haben wir haben wir jetzt das Zahlenwerk durch, dann können wir uns mal die Impfungen anschauen.
Ja, die positiv äh Quoten äh sind.
Auch die positiv Quoteanzahl der äh positiven,
Tests ist jetzt wieder fast auf acht Prozent hochgegangen. Ähm und,
die Anzahl aber der durchgeführten Tests
liegt jetzt immer noch in der Gegend von ja sechs zwischen sechshundert und siebenhunderttausend so, wo, ja, eigentlich fast seit seit einem Monat, äh, sind.
Tests, also ist die Zahl der Tests etwa nur halb so hoch, wie
den gesamten Winter, wo wir regelmäßig äh eins Komma zwei bis eins Kommasechs Millionen Tests hatten und jetzt, wie gesagt, sind wir halt zwischen sechs und achthunderttausend, so dass,
ja auch eine der seltenen Momente haben, wo dann
doch die positiv Rate ähm ja deutlich eben über der der Zahl der der Tests
äh liegt so im.
Im Vergleich, wenn man ungefähr alles maßstäblich darstellt, so in die Spitze bei der Positivquote und die Spitze, bei der Zahl der Tests, denn.
Also wir sind deutlich untertestet eigentlich für.
Wir sind,
deutlich untertestet, also dass wir davon ausgehen können, auch dass im Moment die hm ähm Dunkelziffern relativ hoch sind und,
was da jetzt passiert auf der einen Seite, da kommen wir später noch zu, wird.
Schon ja noch geimpft, also die Zahl der Geimpften vor allen Dingen in bestimmten Altersgruppen äh äh dürfte jetzt grade doch noch ganz gut zunehmen und natürlich jede Infektion,
egal ob erkannt oder unerkannt hm führt natürlich auch zur Immunisierung,
und so impfen plus Ausbreitung der Infektion laufen sich,
ähm ja, liefern sich halt jetzt so ein bisschen ein Wettrennen, äh kann man kann man sagen, oder hm
Ja, es ich habe durchaus Hoffnung, dass wir äh schon äh dann noch so etwas wie Herden
Immunität erreichen möglicherweise, zwar nicht durch Impfung, aber in Kombination eben aus äh Impfung und dann Infektion.
Mhm.
Und da könnte es dann sein, dass wir tatsächlich, also Impfungen plus Infektionen wie.
Möglicherweise Tschechien, äh dass dass wir dann schon äh eine eine Immunisierungs
Quote erreichen, die es dann dem Virus doch schwer macht, äh sich auszubreiten. Ein Haar auszubreiten,
noch sind wir nicht an dem Punkt, definitiv nicht, noch äh gibt's genug potentielle Wirte, äh aber ja, Frage ist, ob die letzten beiden Tage vielleicht eine Indikation dafür sind, dass dass wir
Ähm ja, an einem Punkt kommen, wo sich das dann auch selbst verlangsamt.
Die letzten beiden Tage, die jetzt so leicht nach unten dippen, meinst du, in den Zahlen, ne, okay, das ist natürlich noch ein bisschen frisch, um das äh zu bewerten. Vielleicht sagst du nochmal ganz kurz, wie die Situation in Tschechien ist da im Vergleich?
Na ja, in Tschechien ist mehr oder weniger Ruhe jetzt seit Wochen. Also es ist definitiv keine neue Welle. Da dümpelt es so vor sich hin
auf niedrigen Inzidenzen ohne irgendwie anzusteigen. Polen genau dasselbe. Israel dagegen,
komplett andere Situation. Also das ist definitiv interessant, was ist los in Tschechien und Polen und was ist los in Israel? Was ist da der Unterschied? Das ist gerade so ein bisschen ähm,
unklar. Und eine mögliche Erklärung ist aber, dass halt in Tschechien jetzt Impfung Plus durch Seuchung hm,
Immunisierungsgrad äh ja herstellen, der eben die Zahlen unten hält. Warum das in Israel nicht so ist, aber er schließt sich mir nicht wirklich, weil eigentlich müsste das dort
äh ja mit entsprechend hoher Impfquote und Israel hatte ja auch.
Gerade niedrige Inzidenzen, insofern ja,
ich da so ein bisschen von einem Rätsel, äh warum das in Tschechien und Polen nicht hochgeht und in Israel doch ist.
Ja, vielleicht sollten wir mal das mal kurz ein bisschen genauer äh benennen. Also wenn äh wir halt jetzt grade so mit einer äh Inzidenz um die äh siebzig äh herumdoktoren, siebzig, fünfundsiebzig
Polen und Tschechien berichten halt sehr, sehr, sehr viel niedrigere äh Zahlen, also.
Irgendwie unter fünf und äh Tschechien irgendwie unter unter fünfzehn, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Israel wiederum äh äh dümpelt jetzt irgendwo so nee, dümpelt überhaupt nicht, sondern explodiert äh tatsächlich seit
schon seit einiger Zeit, das ging, äh wann ging das los? Es ging so äh Ende Juni ging das los. Und seitdem ähm sind die Zahlen jetzt auf,
siebenhundert hochge äh geschossen. Dazu muss man wahrscheinlich sich auch nochmal kurz die Positivquote dazu anschauen.
Aber die ist auch in Polen oder in Tschechien extrem niedrig und in Israel ungefähr so wie bei uns, ne? Also.
Irgendwas äh passiert da und ähm.
Wollte ich eh gleich nochmal äh zu sprechen kommen. Der Unterschied dürfte auch sein, dass in Israel die Impfung jetzt schon länger her sind, ne? Und es gibt jetzt so generell den Verdacht,
wir jetzt schon in dieses Auffrischungsproblem äh reinrollen könnten, so, ne. Israel
arbeitet jetzt eben mit Drittimpfung äh entgegen, von daher wird das ganz spannend sein zu sehen, wie sich das jetzt in den nächsten Zeit äh entwickelt.
Ja, die anderen Nachbarländer, äh, wenn ich das so richtig sehe, äh, sind auch ähnlich äh wie Polen und ähm.
Und und Tschechien, also auch da äh also Niederlande ist ungefähr so da, wo wir äh sind, Frankreich, gerade ein bisschen äh besser.
Ähm Schweiz ist ein bisschen äh schlimmer. Ähm.
Österreich hat wiederum auch äh sehr niedrige Zahlen grade. Also es ist äh.
Kein einheitliches äh Bild, aber grundsätzlich kann man sagen ist ist es im Großen und Ganzen alles noch so halbwegs unter Kontrolle. Nur dass halt der der Trend äh in Deutschland gerade noch nicht so richtig toll ist.
So würde ich das mal beschreiben.
Ja. Ja, Frankreich hat ja auch irgendwie das Gefühl, seine sagen die vierte Welle möglicherweise hinter sich, äh so. Ja, alles sehr uneinheitlich.
Schwer irgendwelche ähm.
Daraus ziehen. Gehen wir nochmal ganz kurz auf äh die Impfung, um das äh Bild dann äh abzurunden. Leider, leider, leider, hat das seine.
Sein Datenexport geändert und ich hab mir das noch nicht genau angeschaut, was da eigentlich alles anders ist, auf jeden Fall funktioniert bei 'ne schöne
tolles nicht mehr in dem ich irgendwie diese schönen Grafiken habe die so ein bisschen nach meinem Gusto waren deswegen muss ich jetzt
vorübergehend einfach mit der Visualisierung des Impf-Dashboards und was mir sonst noch so entgegen geflogen ist, arbeiten. Ich.
Versuchen, das wieder aufzunehmen und äh muss er quasi jetzt mich eine andere Datenbasis anschließen, mal schauen, ob mir das ähm einfach fallen wird.
Aber auch so die Auswertung, wo impft der Sport sind, ganz interessant, zumal da auch eine ganze Menge Neues hinzugekommen ist. Also da hat sich auch erfreulicherweise auf dieser Webseite einiges getan.
Grundsätzlich sehen wir uns jetzt erstmal mit einer Erstimpfquote von 65 Prozent und einer.
Zweitimpfquote von 60,5 Prozent. Man sieht schon, die beiden Zahlen sind sich sehr nahe gekommen. Also wir haben jetzt äh eine eine lange lange Phase von abnehmender Erstimpfung gehabt, die nur
bisschen angezogen ist äh vor ein paar Wochen,
weiß nicht, ob sich das gehalten hat. Das ist jetzt so eine äh erst, so eine Auswertung, die ich jetzt aus diesen anderen Visualisierungen nicht so ohne Weiteres herauslesen kann, aber das werde ich noch mal versuchen nachzuholen.
Mit anderen Worten, wir nähern uns einer.
Zwei Drittel voll Verimpfung an der Bevölkerung wohlgemerkt, ne? Das ist ja dann nochmal ein bisschen mehr, wenn man sich nur die Zahl der Leute anschaut, die,
tatsächlich hätten auch geimpft werden können. Bei den.
Zwölf bis ähm warte mal, wie ist das hier aufgeschlüsselt den.
Also die die zwölf plus, zwölf bis siebzehn Jahre, also das ist ja auch wirklich das Albernde. Wir haben ja keine guten Zahlen, ne. Äh wir haben das ja auch schon mehrfach beklagt.
Es wird einfach nicht gut erfasst. Äh vor ein paar Wochen kam ja das RKI noch mit dieser Meldung mit so, ja, wir haben mal eine Umfrage gemacht und laut Umfrage,
sind ja äh
sehr viel mehr Leute gesagt, dass sie zur Info gegangen sind als wir jetzt hier irgendwie erfasst haben und auch wenn ich mir total sicher bin, dass viele Sachen nicht korrekt gemeldet wurden. Es
begeisterte seit Wochen diese Meldung rum, dass viele Betriebsärzte, die ja dann vor ein paar Monaten angefangen haben, auch mitzuimpfen, dann überhaupt nicht ans Meldesystem angeschlossen waren angeblich.
Wo ich mich auch frage, wo ist das Problem, da eine Webseite aufzurufen, weil sehr viel mehr ist das ja auch nicht äh unterm Strich. Ja, und dass es dann vielleicht irgendwann mal nachgereicht wurde, aber es gab dann auch nie irgendwie so einen,
Nachmeldeschub, dass das äh irgendwie klar wurde, dass das dir dann auch erfasst wurden. Jetzt meint das RKI vielleicht stimmen ihre Zahlen auch gar nicht, aber wir hatten das letzte Woche in unserer Clubhausdiskussion ja auch schon mal aufgegriffen das Thema und uns mal so die Impfzahlen,
in Nachbarländern angeschaut, so generell in Europa.
Und wir haben ja die Situation, dass jetzt, sagen wir mal, die Debatten mögen sich vielleicht im Detail und ihrer in ihrem Timing ein bisschen,
unterscheiden, aber so im Großen und Ganzen fährt Europa dasselbe Regime und vor allem bekommt ja auch Europa die selbe Menge an im Show, also innerhalb der EU gibt's die äh den Verteilungsschlüssel, sodass jetzt hier
alleine keinerlei Verzerrungswettbewerb dargestellt haben. Und wenn man sich das halt anschaut, müsste im Prinzip diese bekloppte schlechte Rückmeldung
überall stattgefunden haben. Das sehe ich nicht. Von daher würde ich sagen, vermutlich sind ein paar mehr Leute geimpft, als wir jetzt hier offiziell sehen.
Aber bestimmt nicht so viel, dass es irgendwie wert ist, darüber zu diskutieren. Was was haben wir also jetzt? Wir haben eine Erfassung, die ausschließlich.
Unterscheidet zwischen, man ist älter als 60 oder man ist älter als.
17 Jahre, also nicht ganz richtig, also 60 plus und 18 plus, das sind die beiden Kategorien, in denen bisher erfasst wurde.
Und jetzt kommt quasi neu dazu, zwölf bis siebzehn. Das alles, ja?
Und ich kann es nicht verstehen. Ich ich verstehe das nicht, warum das so sein muss. Ich meine, man liefert alle möglichen Daten ab.
Und wo ist das Problem zu melden, wie alt jemand ist.
Wenn man diese Impfung meldet, ich meine mindestens in zehner Jahresschritten wäre doch schon mal ein Schritt nach vorne.
Ob man 18 ist oder 59, macht für mich einfach einen riesen Unterschied, wenn man darüber nachdenkt, wie man jetzt eine Bevölkerung motiviert, geimpft zu werden, das ist doch vollkommen klar, dass man mit 59-jährigen ganz anders reden muss
als mit 18-jährigen, aber diese Daten existieren einfach nicht.
Ja.
Einfach dadrauf, darüber überhaupt eine, eine, eine, eine Zahl, mit der man arbeiten kann. Oder mal das Geschlecht zu unterscheiden.
Ja? Haben wir einen Unterschied bei Männern und Frauen? Lassen sich Frauen mehr impfen, lassen sich Frauen weniger impfen? Wir wissen es nicht. Und wenn wir es nicht wissen, dann können wir da auch keinerlei Überlegungen anstellen. Und das macht mich einfach wahnsinnig.
Nochmal kurz auf die Zahlen. Also, angeblich laut Impf-Dashboard haben wir also eine Impfquote, ich sage mal jetzt mal hier, vollständig geimpft.
Vierundachtzig Prozent bei sechzig plus. Ist okay. Ist nicht gut, aber es ist okay. Wir haben eine Impfquote von.
65 Prozent bei 18 bis 59. Das entspricht in etwa dem Bevölkerungsmittel und ähm.
Sagt doch viel darüber aus, wie wie viel alte Leute wir haben. Ähm und 12 bis 17 Jahre.
Sind viereinhalb Millionen Leute die das betrifft. Da sind wir jetzt bei einer Erstimpfquote, da ist natürlich der Unterschied zwischen Erst- und Zweitimpfung noch relativ groß. Wir haben also jetzt 31,4 Prozent, die schon ihre erste Impfung,
erhalten haben. Mit anderen Worten, da ist noch eine große Dynamik drin, da nehmen die Zahlen jetzt sehr schnell äh zu, während das in den anderen Segmenten eher träge äh läuft, ne.
Freut mich schon mal sehr, dass schon mal so ein Drittel von zwölf plus äh geimpft ist, aber da bleiben natürlich dann auch immer noch diejenigen, die ähm noch nicht zwölf Jahre äh sind, auch wenn ich auch wenn es so sowas wie Off-Label Impfungen auch gibt, ne, also es gibt.
Ärzte, die auch jüngere Kinder äh impfen, aber das dann halt äh nicht bestätigen können. Ja, was machen wir da jetzt.
Aus. Also es ist ähm die Dynamik ist.
Raus. Es gibt einen leichten Anstieg in den äh letzten Wochen. Offensichtlich hat diese ganze Debatte um Verschärfungen ähm.
Ankündigung von.
Lotto Lotto Verlosung unter äh Geimpften, all diese kleinen Maßnahmen, mobile Impfteams, zusätzliche Ansprache, eine gewisse,
Bewegung erzeugt, also es gibt schon so ein paar Leute, die sich dann doch noch aufgerafft haben und vielleicht äh das äh steht natürlich auch noch zu vermuten, haben wir jetzt auch Sommerferienende.
In zunehmenden Maße in allen äh Ländern, sodass eben auch all die, die jetzt warum auch immer
Jahre Impfung auf das Ende der Sommerferien gelegt haben, dass äh dass das jetzt auch eine Rolle spielt. Ähm zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo wir jetzt äh drüber reden, 31. August haben wir noch Sommerferien in Baden-Württemberg und Bayern.
Bremen, gut, das fällt nicht so sehr rein. Bremen hat auch die besten Impfzahlen in Deutschland, muss man mal dazu sagen
morgen enden die Sommerferien in Niedersachsen. Sachsen hat noch drei Tage.
Sachsen-Anhalt auch noch einen Tag und Thüringen noch ein paar Tage. Also das meiste ist durch und dann kommt noch mal Bayern und Baden-Württemberg, sodass sich also ein bisschen die Hoffnung habe, dass wir in den nächsten zwei Wochen zumindest im Süden nochmal steigende Zahlen äh sehen, aber das ist äh eine.
Eine dünne Hoffnung, ja.
Hm. Ja, wenn ich mir das so angucke
bedeutet das, dass wir wahrscheinlich äh noch so na ja über 60, 23,7 Millionen Menschen.
Über 60, 15 Prozent davon sind ungeimpft und dann mal sagen, bei einer 90prozentigen Effektivität äh der der Impfung äh bedeutet das, dass sich
Ja, effektiv noch, äh ich sage mal drei Millionen Ungeimpfte über sechzig
anstecken können und wahrscheinlich nochmal in derselben Größenordnung Geimpfte über sechzig, ja, das heißt, wir haben allein da nochmal
Bayern, über 60 noch potenziell 6 Millionen äh Wirte und die Hälfte davon sind natürlich äh ungeimpft und dadurch.
Auch nochmal hochgefährdet für ja, schwere Verläufe oder Tod. Ja, das äh und.
Mal wissen. Ja, also da da ist da lauert auf jeden Fall äh noch noch äh Potenzial und wenn wir dann.
Uns den den Rest dann angucken, also jetzt von lasst mal die Kinder äh raus, aber allein nur im Bereich achtzehn bis äh neunundfünfzig sind's halt auch noch zwei Drittel äh komplett,
Ungeimpft, das heißt, dort haben wir rund 16 Millionen potenzielle Wirte, hm?
Ein Drittel ist umgeimpft.
Ein Drittel habe ich zwei Drittel eher ein zwei Drittel sind geimpft, ein Drittel ist ungeimpft
und das heißt, wir haben da rund 16 Millionen potenzielle Wirte äh so im Alter von
18 bis 59 Jahren, ja? Und das reicht dem Virus äh äh natürlich aus, um sich da im Moment noch, noch weiter zu verbreiten.
Auf der anderen Seite äh müssten wir natürlich äh wieder äh jetzt die Zahl äh derjenigen, äh die sich infiziert haben.
Ähm nehmen die ja auch immunisiert äh worden sind äh durch dann eben die
Erkrankung oder äh durch die Infektion.
Nennen wir es natürliche Immunisierung.
Ja, würde ich, ja, natürlich Immunisierung äh ja. Ähm genau und ähm,
Ja, wenn wir, wenn wir da jetzt uns mal anschauen, kommulativ äh was wir denn so hatten äh
bisher, dann ja, sind wir in,
Deutschland ungefähr haben sich fünf Prozent rund, wenn ich das richtig sehe, offiziell bisher mit mit Covid,
infiziert werden's in Tschechien rund 16 Prozent der Bevölkerung wahr. Jetzt muss man aber noch äh ja, das mit einem Faktor irgendwo zwischen zwei und vier
multiplizieren mindestens, um auf die Zahlen inklusive dunkel
Öziffer äh zu kommen. Das heißt, dass wir in Deutschland zwischen irgendwo 10 bis 20 Prozent noch ungefähr an äh natürlicher Immunisierung haben
Und äh ja, in Tschechien so 30 bis 50 Prozent der Bevölkerung natürlich immunisiert sind.
Ja
Aber in Polen äh wiederum äh ja hat, woher die Zahlen auch nicht hochgehen. Die haben so acht, also sieben Komma sechs Prozent ungefähr jetzt an natürlichen äh
Immunisierungen äh so äh mindestens mal Faktor drei, also zwanzig Prozent
ungefähr in Polen. Ja.
Wissen wir natürlich nicht, wie viele von denen, die sich infiziert haben und das vielleicht nie gemerkt haben, äh dann trotzdem auch noch mit in die Gruppe der Impfungen einzurechnen ist. Da kann man jetzt, glaube ich, nur raten.
Genau, das ist halt schwierig, dass man das nicht einfach addieren kann, sondern es wahrscheinlich Leute gibt, die sich genau äh die geimpft wurden äh sind, weil sie gar nicht wussten, dass sie vorher schon mal natürlich äh immunisiert worden sind,
Ja, hm.
Und die vor allem
dann auch, also sagen wir mal, man hat sich infiziert, hat's nicht gemerkt oder ist zumindest nicht offiziell festgestellt worden oder man ist trotzdem einfach äh zur Doppelimpfung äh gelatscht. Ja, das sind ja dann im Prinzip die Leute, die auch dreifach immunisiert wurden und wie sich jetzt
abzeichnet, sind das wiederum Leute, die einen besonders hohen Schutz haben. Also,
Das ist jetzt wirklich alles auch überhaupt nicht mehr nachvollziehbar und ich denke, da kann man bestenfalls mit so einem ja, weiß ich nicht, so so einem statistischen Pi mal Daumenmodell in irgendeiner Form auf eine Zahl kommen. Tatsache ist
noch haben wir genug Durchlaufpotential. Das Virus hat noch genug zu fressen. Und es ist ähm noch nicht absehbar,
wann hier der Lauf gestoppt werden kann in einem Maß, wo man sagen kann, okay, alles klar, jetzt das Schlimmste ist vorbei.
Also es kann, wie gesagt, es kann hinkommen so, dass wir sagen jetzt in der letzten Welle dann quasi nochmal mit
impfen und die natürlicher Immunisierung äh dann an einen
Punkt com in den nächsten Monaten, wo es dann einfach von alleine äh anfängt, zurückzugehen. Das ist durchaus möglich und die Frage ist halt,
ob wir äh diesen Punkt.
Erreichen, äh ohne irgendwelche Maßnahmen äh dann noch treffen äh zu müssen, um,
ja das Gesundheitssystem wieder zu schützen,
und da ist es halt auch noch so, dass gerade bei Mitarbeitern im Gesundheitswesen da brodelt's gerade. Da brodelt's gerade so richtig und die haben gerade so richtig keinen Bock
auf äh eine neue Welle, sowas von gar nicht
ähm ja, also äh das ist das ist jetzt zusätzlich nochmal ein Problem, dass die gerade reihenweise dabei sind. Einfach die hinzuschmeißen.
Bevor wir, bevor wir auf diese ganze Diskussion kommen, was denn jetzt die richtigen Strategien wären, um all das äh zu verhindern. Lasst uns noch die ähm diesen ganzen Impfungsteil,
vielleicht nochmal abschließen. Also ja deutschen Zahlen haben wir uns ja geäußert, auch schon ein paar andere einerseits gab's ja auch neue Bewegungen, zum Beispiel bei der die jetzt dann auch endlich die Impfung von äh Kindern final
ähm gefordert hat, ja.
Mhm. Empfiehlt.
Ja scheint sich noch nicht bei allen Ärzten äh rumgesprochen haben, habe ich so den äh Eindruck, äh.
Auch schon mal so anekdotisch auf äh Ärzte getroffen, die äh davon auch noch gar nichts mitbekommen haben oder meinen zumindest davon nichts mitbekommen äh zu haben, aber grundsätzlich ist es halt jetzt einfach generell die Empfehlung
12 plus einfach mal.
Äh impfen bitte, ja, also solltet ihr da auch noch irgendwelche Zweifel gehabt haben, ich denke, die Faktenlage ist da sehr eindeutig. Erstens, Kinder sind gefährdet, ja?
Nicht nur die Vorerkrankungen alle,
ja? Die Zahlen mögen nicht so hoch sein et cetera, kann man sich lange drüber unterhalten, wie hoch jetzt irgendeine Wahrscheinlichkeit ist, aber es gilt im Prinzip, wie bei den älteren auch, wer sich impfen lässt, hat einfach äh sehr viel höhere Chancen ähm,
hier äh nicht äh äh in Nachteile zu geraten und das sollte das einzige Kriterium sein, meiner Meinung nach.
In Israel wiederum, ich hab's schon angedeutet, ist es so, dass man eben glaubt, dass diese hohe Inzidenz,
auch ein bisschen was äh damit zu tun hat, dass eben die Impfwirkung zu sehr nachlässt. Und das ist natürlich schwer einzuschätzen
Deswegen hat sich Israel äh entschlossen, eine Drittempfung zu verordnen, ne, also ohne, dass es jetzt schon eine neue.
Ähm Impfstoffformel gäbe,
haben wir ja schon ein paar Mal drüber diskutiert, dass vielleicht eine Dritteimpfung dann schon optimiert ist auf die neuen Varianten. Grundsätzlich zeigt sich aber auch, äh,
Obwohl neue Varianten infektiöser sind, sind sie nicht in dem eigentlichen Sinne tödlicher. Also oft vermutet worden, aber hat sich eigentlich bisher noch überhaupt,
tätig. Soweit ich das sehe. Und äh es zeigt sich jetzt allerdings, dass bei denen die Dreifachimmunisiert sind.
Also durch die Impfung, die also dreifach geimpft sind, dass der Schritt von der zweiten zu dritten Impfung nochmal die Wahrscheinlichkeit ähm gegenüber den nur doppelt Geimpften irgendwie um Faktor sechs erhöht
So, also dass dass man sozusagen, dass dass der Schutz nochmal um Faktor sechs erhöht wird. Und das finde ich irgendwie eine ganz ordentliche Zahl.
Die Regelung ist jetzt, dass alle, die älter sind als 30 Jahre und deren Impfung mehr als fünf Monate zurückliegt, die kriegen eine dritte Impfung.
Muss man mal schauen, wie, wie, wie schnell es da voran geht. Ähm während ich das gerade sage, fällt mir ein, dass ich ja hier.
Israel-Webseite auch in meinem Bookmax habe. Äh da werde ich gleich nochmal nachschauen, äh wie's denn da so läuft.
Ähm wo habe ich das? Ah hier, genau.
Schönes Starter-Dashboard. Ich bin ein bisschen neidisch auf die Situation in Israel, nicht wegen der hohen Inzidenz, sondern weil die natürlich einfach gnadenlos wirklich alle Daten haben und da wirklich äh.
Sprechende Auswertung auch machen können.
Mal schauen, äh ach Gott, jetzt hier wieder alles auf hebräisch. Äh okay, das hat sich ein bisschen geändert. Da muss ich noch mal noch mal nachschauen. Äh Trittimpfung, weiß ich nicht, ob die hier schon vermerkt ist.
Auf jeden Fall, das ist die Situation in Israel, da. Jetzt ähm ist die Frage, wie es mit Impfungen weitergeht.
Tja.
Noch kurz äh ein paar Impfstoff News. Ähm also biontech ist jetzt in USA, vollständig zugelassen.
Es war ja bisher auch immer so eine vorläufige Zulassung, aber ist jetzt quasi der der erste Impfstoff, der auch so richtig die vollständige äh Zulassung erhalten hat.
Ja, während bei uns war der aber immer schon vollständig zugelassen in dem Sinne, also oder.
Ähm ja, also so eine Zulassung ist, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, generell im ersten Schritt ähm immer irgendwie vorläufig.
Sondern sozusagen diese vollständige Zulassung kann erst nach soundso vielen Jahren dann auch erfolgen. In den USA war es eher so, da sind die Regelungen ein bisschen anders, dass es so quasi eine Notfallzulassung war.
Und sie jetzt äh den diesen Status von vollständiger Zulassung haben, aber.
Jetzt nicht nachbohren, da kenne ich jetzt die äh juristischen, medizinischen Details nicht genau. Das war auf jeden Fall die Meldung, dass äh das jetzt eben sozusagen gilt.
Ja und dann gab's ja noch sehr viel Berichte über mögliche Probleme mit Herzmuskelentzündungen.
Ähm gab's jetzt auch wieder einen Fall in äh Neuseeland, wo es irgendwie einen Todesfall gab, wo man irgendwie gerade sich sicher zu sein äh
scheint, dass das äh mit der Impfung zusammenhängt, die da halt eine Herzmuskelentzündung ausgelöst hat. Grundsätzlich gilt aber Herzmuskelentzündungen sind.
Selten sind in der Regel auch gut zu behandeln, wenn sie auftreten und treten.
Dass es auch wiederum eine Analyse aus Israel äh.
Sehr viel häufiger auf bei einer natürlichen Infektion. Also in dem Moment, wo man Covid-19 bekommt, ist äh diese Herzmuskelentzündung auch eine Nebenwirkung.
Die auftreten äh kann und die ist halt äh mindestens vier, vier Mal so hoch. Ja, das ist so das, was ich jetzt so mitbekommen habe.
Ja, es gibt,
auch noch in dem Zusammenhang eine Vermutung, dass ähm sagen.
Herzmuskelentzündungen auch
dadurch verursacht werden bei der bei der Impfung das versehentlich in eine Vene statt in den Muskel äh geimpft wird, weil normalerweise ist es so, wenn man.
Den Muskel impft, äh bleibt eigentlich der Großteil von dem Impfstoff innerhalb von ein paar Zentimetern eigentlich
um die Einstichstelle, also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich irgendwie der gesamte Impfstoff äh durch den gesamten äh Körper äh verbreitet. Wenn ich aber natürlich,
eine treffe, dann ja, dann kann das halt schon passieren, dass der an alle möglichen Stellen kommt in größerer Konzentration als das der Fall ist, wenn ich in den Muskel äh.
So das schien mir zumindest eine gewisse Plausibilität zu haben, dass das äh sein der Grund sein könnte.
Genau, das war jetzt eine Untersuchung in Hongkong, in der Hongkong University. Daran kam dieser Bericht her
vielleicht zur Ergänzung, soweit ich das verstanden habe, wenn man sich die gesamte Körperaktivität anschaut, wir hatten da glaube ich mal so einen Link dazu, haben wir das auch schon mal besprochen, weiß ich nicht ganz genau, aber es geht auf jeden Fall
Wie du sagst, äh alles spielt sich äh im Wesentlichen in diesem angestochenen Muskelbereich ab.
Wohl in den ersten Tagen nochmal so eine kurze Interaktion über die Milz.
Die zu erwarten ist, die dann aber auch wieder abflaut und ansonsten bleibt dieses äh Geschehen tatsächlich auf den ähm auf diesen äh,
beimpften Muskelbereich im Wesentlichen beschränkt. Ja, das kann natürlich auch sein, dass das gar nicht so sehr ein
Effekt der Impfung als solcher ist, sondern eher ein äh ein Effekt einer nicht ordnungsgemäß durchgeführten Impfungen.
Mhm. Plus äh was dann auch in dem Zusammenhang jemals so auch schon schon gesagt, also speziell diese Art von Herzmuskelentzündungen, die durch die
Impfung äh verursacht werden, sind natürlich in der Regel unproblematischer, weil der Impfstoff sich nicht vermehrt, sondern abgebaut wird, sozusagen. Das ist dann während wenn ich jetzt
mit dem Virus infiziert bin, dann habe ich halt diese Sicherheit nicht, dann kann sich natürlich äh die Viruslast äh äh auch am am Herzmuskel entsprechend äh dann ja deutlich erhöhen oder gibt's dann kein Limit
im Gegensatz zum Impfstoff so. Das heißt beim Impfstoff halt dann in der Regel von alleine abklingt,
beim, ja, bei einer Virusinfektion und Herzmuskelentzündungen sind ja grundsätzlich nicht nur jetzt bei
sondern generell äh bei ganz vielen äh Virusinfektionen, wenn man sich dann auch noch körperlich zu sehr anstrengt
besteht halt dann dieses Risiko. Also Leute, die dann somit Grippe oder oder schweren grippalen Infekt
äh sich äh dann Sport machen oder so. Es ist typisch, also ja sich körperlich anstrengen.
Da war das schon immer so, dass das da gefallene Herzmuskelentzündung besteht. Ja.
Ja, aber.
Zweifel gibt es nach wie vor an der Wirksamkeit der Impfstoffe an an sich so ähm sowohl.
Es gilt halt immer noch, dass man weniger infektiös ist, selbst wenn man geimpft ist und sich wieder
ansteckt. Das ist ja so ein gängiges Meme, gerade wenn man ähm mit Zweiflern diskutiert, ich sage jetzt mal nicht den Leugnern, sondern
also den Leuten, die halt wirklich so Bedenken haben und sie auch immer noch äh haben. Und dann kommen halt oft so Argumente mit, naja gut ähm
Ich habe ja gehört, man kann sich ja trotzdem äh noch anstecken, wenn man geimpft ist. So ja klar, das war eh klar, weil wir vorhin auch nochmal betont haben,
Niemand hat jemals behauptet, dass der Impfstoff zu 100 Prozent äh wirksam ist, sondern er ist halt zu neunzig Prozent wirksam, das heißt bei zehn Prozent.
Kann es kann der normale Vorgang in irgendeiner Form auch stattfinden, aber selbst mit
der Deltavariante, die ja ähm gezeigt hat, dass sie da sich hervorragend äh weiterverbreitet und so einen extrem hohen
natürlichen Ehrwert hat. Selbst dort ist jetzt äh aus Untersuchungen klar geworden, dass ähm einerseits,
die äh Leute, die geimpft sind und sich.
Trotzdem noch infizieren mit Delta, dass äh zwar die Viruslast bei ersten Messungen,
gleich hoch erschienen und da dachten ja alle schon so, oh Gott, äh jetzt wirkt es irgendwie gar nicht mehr. Nur Virus bedeutet noch lange nicht, dass diese Viren, die dort ähm,
entstehen auch tatsächlich in dem selben Maße Vermehrungsfähig sind und das ist wohl ähm der Fall, also die Virus äh lass es gleich, aber die Vermehrungsfähigkeit nimmt ab und vor allem
baut sich auch insgesamt diese Infektiösität dann wiederum schneller ab.
Die, die noch da ist, ne? Also das äh nach ähm ich glaube so nach nah.
Nach fünf Tagen geht das dann auseinander. Das also die Infektiösität von äh Geimpften, die sich infiziert haben, sind noch sehr viel schneller absinkt, als das eben bei Ungeimpften ist.
Ja
Interessant.
Also impfen hilft, auch gegen Delta.
Ich hatte mir dann auch nochmal bei Israel, die haben ja diese schönen Zahlen, wo man dann auch,
sich anschauen kann, wie viel Prozent jetzt in welcher Altersgruppe äh geimpft oder ungeimpft,
angesteckt waren, Hospitalisiert äh sind oder gestorben sind. Da kann man sich dann auch die.
Die Quoten angucken und sieht dann, dass das auch natürlich nach Altersgruppe sehr stark variiert, aber Größenordnungsmäßig ähm
ja äh sieht man überall so einen Faktor zwischen fünf und zehn. Bei manchen Altersgruppen,
geht der Faktor auf auf zwei äh runter, also meine ich jetzt Schutzfaktor durch Impfung vor, entweder ähm.
Schweren Verlauf, aka Hospitalisierung äh oder eben äh Tod oder ja Ansteckung überhaupt. Und wie gesagt, Altersgruppen abhängig, aber so,
wenn man mit dem mit dem großen Daumen ja fünfmal weniger äh Risiko äh zu sterben, wenn man sich infiziert hat und fünfmal äh geringere Wahrscheinlichkeit für einen schweren.
Und 'ne fünf bis zehn Mal geringere Wahrscheinlichkeit sich überhaupt zu infizieren, na?
Für für Kinder und Jugendliche und ältere noch ein bisschen anders aussieht, aber das kann man sich dort äh auf der israelischen Webseite angucken, Cebration nicht mächtig äh ist, dann halt.
Irgendeinem Browser, der das übersetzen kann und ja.
Ja und äh zu all den ähm Dingen, die wir ja ansprechen und die ganzen Behauptungen, die wir auf äh stellen.
Auch wenn wir jetzt nicht im Einzelnen immer auf die einzelnen Studien so unmittelbar verweisen, ihr findet in immer die Links dazu, ja? Also versuchen ja irgendwie nix zu berichten, was wir nicht auch
konkret irgendwo äh gelesen haben und ähm die Quelle dann auch für halbwegs glaubwürdig halten.
Damit kommen wir so ein bisschen zu der Frage, welche Maßnahmen machen denn jetzt eigentlich äh
Sinn. Äh ich denke, wir sind uns einig da drin, dass wir die Lockdown-Diskussion gar nicht groß aufbringen müssen, weil der Zustand, in dem sich die Gesellschaft grade befindet
Bundestagswahl wird das ohnehin verhindern, es ist hier der von Armin Laschet so ja mit mir als Kanzler wird es niemals ein Lockdown geben, ja
Wo ich mich halt immer frage so von.
Für neue Viren so, also ist das so so genereller Ausschluss, den er da macht, dass äh jetzt so die nächste Pandemie nicht äh ordentlich bekämpft wird.
So, äh gut, lassen wir das. Ähm ich denke, darüber müssen wir gar nicht groß reden. Jetzt ist natürlich die große Frage.
Wie können wir diese, ja, doofes Wort, ja, diese Normalisierung unter den Umständen ähm herbeiführen, weil.
Mehr als noch zu Beginn, würde ich sagen, steht jetzt die Konsolidierung der.
Einerseits der Wirtschaft und damit meine ich aber der Gesellschaft äh auf dem Programm. Wir haben jetzt.
Einige Branchen gehabt, die so hart getroffen wurden von diesem ganzen Lockdown, ja? Und wir haben einige gehabt, die.
Überhaupt nicht betroffen waren oder kaum betroffen waren. Wir haben auch welche gehabt, die haben geboomt, ja, Online-Handel,
Lieferservices et cetera ist klar, das sind so ein bisschen die Kriegsgewinnler. Da kann man auch herzlich wenig gegen machen und das ist ja auch äh gut, wenn es äh auf der anderen Seite Bereiche gibt, die dann potenziell auch Personal aufgenommen haben, aus anderen Branchen, sodass
Die Leute jetzt erstmal nicht so betroffen waren, aber das Problem ist natürlich, dass jetzt diese Gebäude in Branchen und ich nenne jetzt einfach mal so ein paar. Das ist natürlich die äh Gastronomie.
Das ist äh die äh ja generell Bewirtung und Hotellerie, die ähm natürlich mega getroffen war und es ist äh im im ganz breiten Maße auch die Kultur, der Sport.
Solche Branchen und diese die wünschen sich glaube ich vor allem
Alle eins, nämlich, dass man jetzt nicht wieder irgend so einen neuen Eiertanz macht, dass man jetzt nicht einen Weg einschlägt, der nicht potenziell eine lineare Verbesserung der Situation im im Auge hat
weil ich glaube, dass dass wäre jetzt sozusagen das, was was vielen
Rettungsversuchen und vielleicht gelungenen Rettungsversuchen, die schon stattgefunden haben, äh auf den letzten Metern nochmal das Genick brechen könnte.
Gibt ja solche Aspekte wie hast du wahrscheinlich auch äh viel drüber gelesen, dass ähm viele.
Restaurants, Bars, Cafés.
Sich vielleicht jetzt darauf eingestellt haben, schon in diesem Sommer wieder mehr Gäste zu haben, weil Inzidenzwiedrig et cetera Leute passen wieder ein bisschen mehr Vertrauen und im Sommer ist indoor nicht so wichtig. Ja, das mag für manche funktioniert haben,
Dass sie dann aber teilweise mit diesem Boom nicht klar kamen, weil sie schlicht und ergreifend kein Personal mehr gefunden haben.
Wirkt jetzt erstmal so ein bisschen äh verstörend, dieser Gedanke, so nach dem Motto, wieso habt ihr denn Personalsorgen äh so viele Leute müssten doch jetzt auf der Suche nach äh nach Job sein.
Stimmt im Prinzip, aber man muss auch sagen, Gastronomie war schon immer relativ schlecht bezahlt.
Relativ hoher Arbeitslast, also eine hohe Belastung, lange Zeiten, ja? Einziger Vorteil bei der Gastronomie, das ist so ein bisschen so diese Feier an Forget äh Berufe.
Während du bei einer Büroarbeit und so normalen Firmen deinen Job nie komplett an der Garderobe abgibst, ist das so in der Gastronomie seltener das Thema, ne? Also wenn du da irgendwie Schluss hast, dann.
Beginnt danach nur Freizeit und und und die Bestellung von vor einer halben Stunde, die du da äh noch durchgeführt hast.
In deinem Leben keine Rolle mehr. Trotzdem sehen einfach diese gastronomischen Betriebe das Problem, dass sie einfach jetzt kein Personal mehr bekommen, weil die halt die Rechnung aufmachen. Erstens, okay, das war immer sehr anstrengend. Zweitens, ich habe nicht sehr viel verdient.
Drittens, ich habe vielleicht jetzt in der letzten Zeit zwangsläufig, andere Branchen kennengelernt, wo vielleicht auch nicht alles Gold ist, was glänzt, aber wo ich zumindest diese Perspektive habe, dass es diesen Job auch noch in einem Jahr habe und jetzt habe ich ihn auch schon.
Ne? Und das dann halt einfach viele nicht zurückkommen und dass selbst die, die potenziell immer noch denken so, naja, eigentlich passt das auch zu mir.
Trotz allem würde ich das gerne machen, aber die Angst haben und das komme ich wieder auf diesen ursprünglichen Punkt zurück, was ist im Winter?
Was es jetzt im November? Was ist wenn die Wahlen durch sind und irgendwie alle jetzt so lange wieder sich damit gerühmt haben, keine Maßnahmen erlassen zu wollen
das halt wieder Infektionszahlen durch die Decke gehen, äh Krankenhäuser wieder zu haben und dann doch wieder die erste Reaktion ist, ja, jetzt müssen wir erstmal wieder alles zumachen, weil Indoor und im Winter ist ja alles viel zu gefährlich.
Und ich glaube, das ist so ein Problem, das lastet auf vielen Bereichen, ja. Ich sehe es beim Fußball, dass es halt so ein Bereich, den ich mir
zwangsläufig ein bisschen näher anschaue, die haben einfach Probleme.
Einerseits das Publikum wieder zurückzuholen, weil natürlich da das Vertrauen noch nicht wieder aufgebaut ist, aber auf der anderen Seite in dem Moment, wo das Publikum kommt, kriegen die einfach die ganzen Ordner, die sie brauchen, auch gar nicht mehr. Weil einfach in dem Moment
diese Ordner,
ja auch nicht einfach so verfügbar sind. Die die regnen nicht auf Knopfdruck von oben ab. Das heißt, wir haben so 'ne langfristige.
Ähm wie soll ich sagen, Disruption.
In unserem wirtschaftlichen Gefüge in all den Branchen, die jetzt aus verschiedenen Gründen von der Pandemie besonders betroffen waren. Und es ist absehbar, dass das ein Zustand ist, der sich, wenn's gut läuft.
Wenn's wirklich gut ausgeht alles sich vielleicht so im Laufe im Sommer nächsten Jahres.
Auflösen könnte für.
75 Prozent der Betroffenen. So würde ich das mal so aus dem Bauch heraus äh bewerten. Und jetzt kommt natürlich die Fragen, was machen wir denn jetzt eigentlich? Was ist denn jetzt richtig, Lockdowns werden's nicht sein? Ja.
Jetzt geht ihr halt die Diskussion los mit 2 G und 3 G.
Sehr lustig. Vorher haben irgendwie die Schwabler äh die ganze Zeit irgendwie über 5 G geredet. Jetzt reden wir wieder über zwei G.
Sprich diese äh geimpft, getestet, genesen äh Regelung, beziehungsweise das ist halt 3G und bei 2G fällt das getestete halt weg, um äh entsprechend Druck zu machen auf Ungeimpfte, denn da das doch mal bitte nachzuholen.
Hamburg macht das jetzt.
Mhm, ja, Nordrhein-Westfalen nicht, als ich Laschet hat sich explizit dagegen entschieden. Laschet will irgendwie
bei drei G bleiben, keine Ahnung, wie er das hinkriegen will, weil wenn ich es richtig sehe, gab es entsprechende Rechtssprechung, die mehr oder weniger Unternehmen
ein Recht auf äh irgendwie zwei G einräumt im Prinzip, ja. Es ist zwar nicht.
Ja und Hamburg hat das in, glaube ich, in Verordnungs äh Form gepackt, äh während irgendwie, ja, NRW äh das das nicht möchte, die möchten halt. Das Getestete nicht ausgeschlossen äh äh werden, von.
Also in Hamburg ist es auch nur eine Option.
Ja ja, aber du kannst, wenn du dann äh kannst dann so oder so optionieren äh während es so wie ich das verstanden habe in NRW unerwünscht ist und es diese Option in dem Sinne äh nicht gibt.
So ja und aber äh noch was.
Äh was heißt nicht, nicht nicht gibt, ist natürlich äh selbstverständlich kannst du als Veranstalter beliebige äh äh Bedingungen äh machen.
Ja, also ja, äh sagen wir so, dass du halt äh dafür scheint es
in in Nordrhein-Westfalen dann in dem Sinne kein Prozess zu geben, beziehungsweise kriegst du dann Probleme oder Stress, weiß ich nicht, wenn du das das machst, äh so im Moment. Das ist zumindest erklärte Politik in NRW
sagen nicht diese Optionsmöglichkeit wie in Hamburg einzuräumen. Es hat Lasche zu gesagt.
Ähm keine Ahnung wie sich das wie sich das entwickelt wird. Aber ich wollte noch eins ergänzen, äh zu der Sache äh wirtschaftliche,
Veränderungen äh dauerhaft ähm der Luftverkehr, Luftfahrt ist natürlich auch äh so eine Branche.
Natürlich extrem betroffen war und da ist jetzt der Effekt, dass sich zwar äh die Passagierzahlen überraschend schnell erholt haben.
Aber äh fast nur bei
Urlaubsreisenden bei den Geschäftsreisenden die sind noch zurückhaltend,
ja, da haben die meisten Büros haben noch geschlossen oder spezielle Auflagen und das Geschäftsreisen ist einfach noch nicht so richtig wieder
zurück, was dazu führt, dass die Mischkalkulation die bestimmte machen, die einen hohen Anteil an Geschäftsreisenden haben, gerade nicht
aufgeht, so die Fliegen halt deswegen mit äh ja äh also die haben, was weiß ich, 80 Prozent der Passagiere, aber nur 65 Prozent der Umsätze
wiederbekommen
während es so gibt, wie was weiß ich, Haus West oder wahrscheinlich auch Ryanair, äh die am halt da ist Umsatz und Passagierzahlen äh
Recovery äh ist dort mehr oder weniger gleich, weil die nur einen sehr kleinen Anteil an Geschäftsreisenden überhaupt.
Hatten und nicht so kalkulieren. Und je nachdem, wie lange das jetzt dauert, äh ist die Vermutung, dass das auch nochmal äh ja die die Luftfahrt äh
nochmal letztlich umstrukturieren wird oder dass äh im Prinzip möglicherweise dauerhaft äh
Geschäftsreisende, äh was Flugverkehr angeht, nie wieder sich äh auf
vor Pandemie Level zurückkehren werden. Das ist so die, weil jetzt viele auch die Infrastruktur geschaffen haben und gesehen haben, dass man auch viel Online machen kann äh und äh ja äh
dann Homeoffice äh wird wahrscheinlich auch äh ein bisschen mehr bleiben, als es als es war. Also
Ja, das fand ich ganz ganz interessant, dass äh wir möglicherweise, ja, oder wahrscheinlich gar nicht äh wieder an den Punkt kommen werden, dass alles so ist wie vorher, sondern dass wir halt bleibende
Veränderungen haben werden.
Ja, davon ist auf jeden Fall auszugehen, also dass, ich meine, das jetzt nichts bleibt davon, ich glaube, das können wir auch vergessen. Die Frage ist halt nur,
Wie kann man ab jetzt.
Ähm soweit das Richtige tun, um auf der einen Seite abzuwägen, okay, wir haben nach wie vor, wie ich finde, die Verpflichtung, diejenigen zu schützen, die sich nicht selber schützen können, sprich die Kinder.
Ja? Also ist natürlich jetzt auch so ein bisschen so eine
wirtschaftlich, ethische Frage, ne? Auf der anderen Seite in Hamburg äh argumentieren jetzt bestimmte Restaurantbesitzer mit, na ja, irgendwie 40 Prozent sind noch nicht noch nicht geimpft, ich wäre nicht auf vierzig Prozent meiner potenziellen Kunden äh verzichten, so dass es so
diese eine Sichtweise. Das andere ist halt ähm okay, man sollte die Maßnahmen hochhalten, um das Infektionsgeschehen in äh Grenzen zu erhalten, damit man eben weiter Zeit gewinnt, weil das ist ja eigentlich das, worum's gerade geht. Wir müssen einfach Zeit gewinnen.
Ja, also es geht, wir sind eigentlich grade wieder, sozusagen, äh, wie am Anfang, fletten the curve.
So ist im Moment äh gerade angesagt, wobei halt jetzt die Kurve äh wegen,
der Impfungen äh deutlich höher sein kann. Wer also nicht so sehr abflachen müssen
wie in vorherigen Wellen, aber nichtsdestotrotz haben wir vorhin die Zahlen genannt, da sind noch äh einfach in Deutschland
Jahr 30 Millionen Menschen, die oder 40 Millionen Menschen, die in die.
Als potentielle Wirte für das Virus in Frage kommen. Und äh ja
das kann man halt im Moment trotzdem noch nicht, deswegen einfach so laufen lassen. Und ich sehe jetzt für die Zukunft.
Zwei Szenarien erstmal. Einmal das Szenario. Hm wir bleiben von.
Varianten verschont die,
die Impfung und vorherige Immunisierung komplett durchbrechen können oder weitgehend komplett durchbrechen können. So, sprich, es bleibt bei Covid-19 und es gibt kein Covid.
21 oder covid22, was das faktisch dann wäre, weil letztlich ähm
ist es, ich sage mal, solange Covid-19 wie jemand, der an einer Variante von Covid-19 erkrankt ist
'ne gewisse Immunität gegen alle Varianten
von Covid-19 aufbaut. Aber wenn da jetzt plötzlich ein Virus ist, der zwar meinetwegen sich aus Covid-19 entwickelt hat, aber sich so weit davon entfernt hat, dass es quasi keine Kreuzimmunität gibt zwischen ja, jetzt Covid-19 und dieser neuen Variante, dann wäre es auch
in dem Sinne, aus meiner Sicht kein Covid-19 mehr, sondern wir hätten's mit einer komplett neuen Pandemie äh zu tun, so,
Diesen Fall nehmen wir mal jetzt weg, so, weil neue Pandemie kann immer kommen. So, dafür gibt's, da gibt's jetzt keine
Sicherheit äh vor, aber das muss man dann meiner Meinung nach auch getrennt und als völlig neue Pandemie betrachten. So
also jetzt bei bei Covidneunzehnähm sehe ich das so,
ist das nicht mehr allzu lange hin bis äh entweder die Impfung oder das Virus.
Praktisch jeden erreicht haben wird bei uns, ja? Und
so gut wie jeden. Also ich rechne damit, dass das in den nächsten Monaten äh sogar der Fall sein wird, abhängig davon, wie flach oder stark jetzt die
die Infektionskurve und die die Impfkurve dann dann verlaufen werden, aber ich gehe äh davon
aus, ja, dass dass wir in den in den nächsten Monaten äh
in diesem Jahr einen Punkt erreicht haben werden, wo das Virus dann keine weiteren Werte mehr in ausreichender Zahl findet und sich eben dann entsprechend selbst äh limitiert
und ähm ja,
Ich meine, wir sind ein bisschen früh dran. Wie gesagt, alles laufen lassen äh zu können, aber im Grunde genommen ist,
der Weg, den man jetzt einschlägt. So nämlich zu sagen, Leute, lasst euch, lasst euch impfen, alles andere,
so werden wir soweit es möglich ist, zurückfahren, wobei auch äh aber die Regierung sagt, naja, wir werden nicht alles,
aufheben, sondern es wird noch ähm ja, bestimmte Beschränkungen oder Auflagen geben in bestimmten Bereichen, also wird nicht alles.
Erstmal weggehen und Frage ist reicht das um die Kurve
ausreichend äh abzuflachen oder muss dann nochmal nachgelegt werden, weil dann doch wieder die Krankenhäuser volllaufen. Und.
Das Potenzial, das die Krankenhäuser volllaufen besteht. Wir haben's aber bisher noch.
In keinem anderen Land gesehen, dass ein größerer Lockdown oder eine massive Verschärfung nötig
geworden wäre. So auch in in UK äh so ähm ja
ist man ja nicht wieder in den Lockdown gegangen und da hat aber auch dann die vierte Welle irgendwann zumindest äh
ist sie ein bisschen zurückgegangen, ist jetzt noch nicht, jetzt könnte man sagen, ist die viereinhalbte grade in in UK, äh äh da, aber zumindest ist es noch nirgendwo so in die Höhe geschossen,
ähm jetzt mit mit den Impfungen, äh dass man,
ja, dass das Gesundheitssystem in in Gefahr wäre und deswegen rechne ich bis auf Weiteres erstmal auch nicht damit, dass das bei uns passiert.
Was natürlich schon noch sein kann, was jetzt kälter wird und äh jetzt auch wieder so ein bisschen ja Saisonalität und äh anderes ähm
die Verbreitung wahrscheinlicher macht,
kannst natürlich jederzeit sein, dass es nochmal aufflackert oder explodiert plus. Hm.
Ist ja nicht gleichmäßig über ganz Deutschland gestreut, so dass wir äh durchaus auch die Gefahren werden, dass es in einzelnen Gebieten, in einzelnen Hotspots dann doch nochmal
eng werden wird, aber ich rechne nicht damit, dass es in ganz Deutschland jetzt nochmal komplett ähm
ja in den Lockdown geht, weil es von sag mal.
Inzidenzen. Also die Inzidenzen müssten dann äh so deutlich über tausend
gehen um uns in diese Situation zu bringen jetzt mit ja bei dem bei dem aktuellen Stand der Impfungen.
So könnte man das, glaube ich, beschreiben. Aber, wie gesagt, äh.
Wenn dann die über tausend gehen sollten, bei zwei, dreitausend, wird's dann trotz Impfung würde es halt super eng werden, aber
Wenn das passieren würde, kann ich mir wiederum vorstellen, dass dann doch nochmal äh ein Haufen Leute, die Meinungen,
und sich dann nochmal impfen,
lässt. Deswegen lässt sich das auch immer schwer vorhersagen, aber generell tendieren solche Wachstumsprozesse limitierend äh äh zu sein. Also es.
Du denkst eine Lockdown-Drohung würde dazu führen, dass Leute sich impfen lassen?
Ja, also wenn, ich sage mal, wenn die Inzidenz irgendwo plötzlich bei 2000 ist, die Krankenhäuser voll sind, ist dann wieder in einzelnen äh Bereichen des Landes so Triagen
gibt und die Leute, was weiß ich dann ins Ausland zur Behandlung gebracht werden müssten oder in andere Gegenden, weil lokal so
dass äh ja, das würde, könnte ich mir vorstellen, könnte vielleicht auch nochmal dazu führen, wenn's wenn's schlimm wird, dass halt
mehr Leute nochmal sich sich impfen lassen.
Ich meine.
Interessante ist ja, wir haben ja gerade das Infektionsgeschehen, wenn ich das jetzt richtig interpretiere. Unserer Hotspot ist ja derzeit so im ist ja NRW, ne?
Ja, also mhm. Ich meine, da ist es.
Und der Osten ist relativ na ja, nicht unbetroffen, aber derzeit grade nicht so sehr.
Zahlen bei oder ist das jetzt schon übertrieben? Ich habe jetzt gerade die Auswertung nach Bundesländern nicht so richtig vor meinem geistigen Auge. Worauf ich hinaus will ist.
Wenn du dir die Impfkarte anschaust, wo eigentlich jetzt wie viel geimpft wurde, dann ist auch sehr auffällig, dass hier der Westen deutlich vor dem Osten liegt.
Also man sieht richtig, also die Hochburg ist ja Bremen, was vielleicht, sagen wir mal, ein bisschen zu klein ist, um wirklich jetzt,
Eine Aussage äh zu machen, aber die sind immerhin so bei bei 75 Prozent.
Der äh Erstimpfung, ich nehme mal lieber Zweitimpfung, da sind sie bei 70 Prozent. Während Sachsen gerade mal bei 15und Kommasechs Prozent ist.
Also ein riesiger äh Sprung so, ne? Okay, gut, Bremen hat eine exzellente Arbeit geleistet
die anderen sind jetzt äh auch nicht jetzt so megaweit vorne. Ähm was haben wir da? Also Schleswig-Holstein.
64,5 Prozent Saarland, 66 Prozent, das sind so die Halbflyer, während die bei den großen Ländern
Bayern ist zu beachten, fünfzig, sieben, Baden-Württemberg bei neunundfünfzig sechs. Gut, da könnte man auch wieder argumentieren, da ist jetzt der Unterschied so groß jetzt auch nicht zu äh
Brandenburg mit was weiß ich, fünfundfünfzig Prozent.
Aber interessanterweise ja liegen halt tatsächlich äh die Ostländer im Moment alle hinten und Sachsen, das ist ja äh in der dritten Welle so oft der Spitzenreiter war ähm.
Ja, da kam ich nämlich jetzt gerade drauf, weil du gesagt hast, wenn dann erstmal die Triage kommt und wir hatten ja auch durchaus diesen
Effekt, dass äh äh in Sachsen, als dann wirklich auf einmal äh in den Krematorien sich irgendwie die Särge gestaut haben, dann äh alle auf einmal ein bisschen aufgewacht sind und dann äh in der Reaktion daraufhin das Verhalten
angepasst wurde, sodass die Inzidenzen wieder zurückgingen. Ich habe so ein bisschen meine Bedenken, ob das wirklich zur Impfung führen wird.
Na ja, es sind ja nicht nur dann die reinen Zahlen, sondern,
Wenn du dann plötzlich solche Inzidenzen hast, dann äh kommen halt die Einschläge auch im.
Direkten in der Bekanntschaft, ja?
Ja, das stimmt net.
Kann dann äh ja, einfach wenn du merkst, oh, das ist jetzt schon der dritte in drei Wochen äh von den Leuten, die ich kenne, die jetzt irgendwie auf der Intensivstation liegen oder nicht mehr zurückgekommen. Das das kann dann, glaube ich, doch schon, wenn plötzlich
ja Covid dein Freundeskreis dann deutlich dezimiert.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen, könnte schon äh den ein oder anderen umdenken lassen.
Das will man immer hoffen, aber äh man weiß ja, äh.
Ne
Das Universum wissen ist nicht unendlich, aber die Dummheit äh äh der Menschen äh auf jeden Fall und ähm von daher mich.
Stimmt es nicht so froh, wenn ich mir solche Zahlen.
Anschaue in Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass es halt eigentlich sich aus allen anderen Zahlen sehr gut ablesen lässt, dass würden sich jetzt alle impfen lassen.
Mhm.
Dann wäre das Ding auch durch.
Hätten wir erstmal Ruhe im Karton.
Ja, ja, also das ist wird wird nicht alles sofort wieder toll sein.
Aber äh es ist der Schlüssel zur Lösung. Und ausgerechnet die Leute, die sich am meisten über die Einschränkungen beklagen, sind jetzt diejenigen, die eigentlich diese Einschränkungen aufrecht erhalten.
Und das wollte ich auch schon immer so in gewisser Hinsicht, aber jetzt bei der Impfung wird's halt auch nochmal ganz offensichtlich und das ja, gut, also es ist hat wenig Sinn darüber äh zu schreien,
immer so.
Ja, also man.
Kann eigentlich sagen äh dass es mit jedem Tag äh im Moment meiner Sicht weniger Gründe gibt, sich nicht.
Zu lassen und mehr Gründe gibt.
Impfen zu lassen. Ja, selbst wenn man jetzt irgendwie sagt, ich bin der super vorsichtige und ich will jetzt nicht irgendwie experimentier äh äh Kaninchen sein, so. Ja, mit jedem Tag äh,
ist das Ganze weniger experimentell, ja? Und.
Leute sind geimpft worden. Wenn's für Milliarden Leute sind geimpft worden, wenn das wirklich ein nennenswertes Problem mit der Impfung gäbe, wüssten wir das schon lange.
Ja, ja. Und gut, heißt es ja, ja, das wird jetzt dann vertuscht und verheimlicht äh und so, aber äh nee. Also ich.
Kinn äh jetzt einfach nur, ich meine, das ist jetzt zwar auch nur anekdotisch, aber es ist doch ein statistisches Sampling so. Also ich,
kenne drei Leute aus dem erweiterten Bekanntenkreis, äh die an Covid-Verstorben sind.
Ja, so. Ähm aber ich kenne niemanden, äh,
aus meinem erweiterten Bekanntenkreis, der irgendwie nennenswerte Probleme äh mit der Impfung gehabt hätte. Also das Schlimmste waren irgendwie zwei oder drei Tage flach gelegen mit.
Äh Fieber so. Ja, das war sagen das Schlimmste von dem ich persönlich gehört.
Klar, ja. Aber das ist äh äh ja.
Bei mir ist es ähnlich. Ich habe zwar keine ich glaube mal überlegen, nee Tote habe ich äh in meinem unmittelbaren Umfeld zumindest nicht so beklagen. Aber auf jeden Fall äh in der äh Abteilung habe ich hätte ich noch einiges zu bieten.
Mhm, also es sind jetzt alles Leute, die ich zwar jetzt persönlich äh nicht alle äh kannte, aber was weiß ich, Mutter von äh äh Freund oder Bekannten oder sowas oder Großeltern von Bekannten, so.
Ja okay gut, da haben wir dann wahrscheinlich auch noch eine Überschneidung. Insofern äh hätte ich dann auch noch einen Fall, aber ist dann derselbe.
Ja, ähm und wie gesagt, mit jedem Tag werden mehr Leute,
geimpft äh mehr Studien werden gemacht, immer mehr wird bekannt über die Wirksamkeit äh.
Möglichen Probleme, die im Zusammenhang mit der Impfung stehen und aber auch äh ja, die Probleme, die Covid verursacht und da kann man ganz klar sagen, egal wie skeptisch
man ist, wenn man vor einem Jahr.
Hätte sagen können, okay äh das ist wirklich ein ganz neues Faxin, ich will da nicht als Erster dabei sein und ähm ja und äh es,
halt ich ich muss es jetzt nicht unmittelbar tun, weil
ohnehin das jetzt erstmal am Anfang nicht so den Unterschied macht. Das kann ich dann verstehen, sagen, wenn Leute äh gesagt haben, ich ich warte erstmal ab.
Ja, der Impfstoff ist eh knapp. Äh es wird auf jeden Fall jemand geimpft, wenn ich nicht geimpft werde. Mhm.
So und ich muss nicht der erste genau, das heißt, so jetzt.
Ist das aber eine andere Situation. Jetzt ist ein Großteil der Leute ist halt jetzt äh geimpft. Es gibt jetzt keinerlei Grund mehr äh irgendwo damit zu warten.
Außer man ist elf.
Ja
Oder zehn. Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall noch ein Faktor, aber das ist nicht das, was wir meinen.
Nee. Und äh ja und auf der anderen Seite.
Lautet jetzt eigentlich nur noch äh mehr oder weniger die Wahl. Ich meine, das war am Anfang auch so, jetzt äh dadurch, dass jetzt auch
sage mal, die Bevölkerung mehr oder weniger zur Durchinfektion freigegeben ist. Ja, nicht komplett, aber weitgehend so. Das heißt, jeder, der sich halt noch nicht hat, impfen lassen
muss sich im Klaren
sein, dass äh ja äh jetzt in den nächsten Monaten nicht allzu viel mehr passieren wird, äh um.
Vor dem Virus zu schützen oder das Virus zu containen, sondern wir werden äh ganz klar äh eine ja
hoffentlich begrenzte Durchseuchung äh sehen. Das ist das jetzt, worauf es politisch hinausläuft.
Ähm wo, ehrlich gesagt, zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt ich auch keine wirklich bessere Alternative.
Sehe. Realistisch äh durchsetzbar,
äh wie auch immer. So, klar, es gibt ganz viele Dinge, äh die Verbesserungswürdig wären. Es gibt auch noch ganz viel Unlogik äh.
In den ganzen Maßnahmen und Begrenzungen, die jetzt noch da sind, ja, ganze Thema irgendwie schulen und auch.
Ja, dass das ja und das ganze Maskentragen ist natürlich schon äh also,
es ist jetzt kein Problem im Supermarkt eine Maske aufzusetzen als als als Einkäufer, aber.
Freundin von mir, die halt Krankenschwester ist, äh die äh ja, die ist.
Auch nur meint, allein mit den Maskentragen. Also früher hätte es dafür
Erschwerniszulage gegeben, wenn du einfach den ganzen Tag von morgens bis abends mit einer FFP-Maske schwere körperliche Arbeit auch noch verrichten musst. So,
und äh ja, äh plus, dass das Ganze ja eigentlich arbeitsschutzrechtlich äh so gar nicht geht, wie das, wie das gehandhabt.
Wird in in in vielen Bereichen, weil du ja eigentlich nach 90 Minuten erstmal sechzig Minuten äh so Ruhephase äh äh haben muss. Das das ist ja.
Wird ja nirgends, passiert ja nirgendwo. Und äh klar sagen, na gut, dann arbeiten die Leute halt mit.
Wie anderen äh Masken so mit mit OP-Masken, wo der Atemwiderstand nicht so das Problem ist, die man dann länger tragen kann, aber die bieten dann wiederum nur Schutz, wenn alle Leute maskiert sind, ja, mit denen kann man sich dann auch nicht,
eigenständig äh schützen. Und wenn du es dann somit teilweise auch Abteilungen hast, äh die zum Beispiel akut,
psychiatrische Dienste bieten, wo es mit Patienten zu tun hast, die einfach
mal ja den du einfach Schutzmaßnahmen äh äh grade mal nicht wirklich vermitteln kannst, weil sie mit drei oder vier Promille eingeliefert werden oder andere äh psychische Probleme haben, ja,
Plus, das ist natürlich die ganzen Arbeitsabläufe auch auf vielen Stationen im Gesundheitswesen
durcheinander bringt, so weil dann plötzlich,
die Betreuung, also äh gemeinsame Essen können dann nicht stattfinden, sondern müssen dann in Gruppen oder den Leuten aufs Zimmer, das Essen gebracht werden und so. Also ganz ganz äh äh ja unten
unschöne Geschichten, äh die da.
Und nicht nur im medizinischen Bereich, ne. Ich meine, das sehen wir alle so, ne? Aber ich denke, so die Grundmaßnahmen, bei der so Maske im Supermarkt.
Also da muss ich schon mittlerweile gar nicht mehr drüber nachdenken. Das ist so eine Automatik äh dass es so komplett ins Kleinhirn äh gewandert, ja.
Und da ist es nun wirklich nicht erforderlich. Ja, ist nicht so, dass man da besonders viel soziale Interaktionen hätte und äh das bisschen an der Kasse, das kriegt man dann irgendwie auch noch hin.
Aber ist schon richtig. Der Rest muss drauf verzichten
äh äh können und das Einzige, was hilft, ist impfen. Also Leute, ihr wisst es eh, wenn ihr diesen Podcast hört, dann seid ihr wahrscheinlich äh
ohnehin äh auf unsere Aufklärung eigentlich gar nicht angewiesen so. Aber vielleicht kann man sich mal merken so, Antikörper werden jetzt auf jeden Fall gebildet. Die Frage ist nur, wodurch, ne, also,
dass das kommt jetzt auf jeden Fall auf uns zu.
Ja, also ja, jeder kann sich das jetzt aussuchen, ob er halt den Impfstoff äh oder irgendeine.
Virusvariante haben will von irgendeinem Typen, der äh irgendwie, keine Ahnung, den ihn nicht kenne, der mir dann irgendein Virusvariante dann äh ja.
Und sind wieder einige Neue im Angebot. Also es gibt jetzt irgendwie C 16. Äh ganz neu und so, das äh äh.
Mhm. Können die was?
Ja, na ja, es ist immer dasselbe Ding wieder mit äh man weiß nicht genau und noch mal höhere Infektionsrate, also ich glaube jetzt steht schon wieder was im Verdacht, äh nochmal zwei, drei Mal äh,
schlimmer zu sein als Delta. Also da ist auf jeden Fall noch steigerungsfähig im Prinzip des
Das Virus ist äh auch in zunehmendem Maße unter Druck durch die ganze Impferei, ja? Also nicht, dass du jetzt weltweit nicht noch genug Leute da wären, wo es sich ausbreiten kann, aber
das das ist halt äh schon so, wobei das Freilaufend noch das größere Problem ist. Das hat sich wohl auch gezeigt, dass.
Äh Länder mit hoher Impfquote, auch weniger zur Mutation beiträgt. Das.
Schon immer von ausgehen können, aber mittlerweile gibt's da wohl auch belegbares äh Zahlenmaterial dazu. Ja, na ja,
Also um das mit den Maßnahmen jetzt vielleicht an der Stelle mal äh abzuschließen, Lockdown wird's nicht äh geben, macht wahrscheinlich auch keinen Sinn. Trotzdem äh
Alles, was wir machen sollte im Idealfall einen linearen
Abnahme äh der der des Maßnahmendrucks auf die Bevölkerung zur Folge haben und dementsprechend ähm sollte man vielleicht dazu beitragen, indem wir jetzt halt nicht nochmal diese vierte Welle,
total ausreizen.
Sondern einfach äh weiter impfen, so es irgendwie äh geht, bitte redet auch nochmal auf alle ein, die bisher äh Argumente vorgebracht haben mit, man weiß ja nicht und so, man weiß jetzt,
Ja, also es ist einfach durch. Das Ding ist durch, man weiß es, es wirkt. Es schadet nicht, es hilft. Und ähm das muss jetzt getan werden.
Genau und für die Impfmuffel hat die Bundesregierung jetzt entschieden, äh das äh Virus jetzt auf die loszulassen, um die dann halt zu immunisieren, ob sie wollen oder nicht. Ja.
Genau. Und am Inzidenz 35, die wir ja schon lange äh erreicht haben, äh müssen halt betroffene Städte und Kreise äh diese Tests nach wie vor äh verlangen.
Und ab 11. Oktober, wenn ich das richtig sehe, sind die dann auch nicht mehr kostenlos.
Hm. Ja, so, ja. Ja, ja, ja. Mhm.
Und in dem Zusammenhang sind natürlich diese zwei Regelungen dann auch äh nochmal ein extra äh äh Druck, die ich für viele Bereiche angemessen sehe. Ich sehe aber auch, dass viele grade so im im gastronomischen Bereich.
Halt auch viel Schreierei, ne. Dann laufen halt, ich meine, wie würdest du dich fühlen, wenn du in so einem in so einem Beruf arbeitest, wo du also permanent auf Leute, die du nicht kennst.
Die dich nicht kennen und die eigentlich auch einen Scheiß auf dich geben, triffst, ja, also irgendwo an der Kasse äh äh bis in irgend so einem Laden, verdienst da eh nicht viel äh Geld, dann möchtest
sich nicht auch noch äh anschreien lassen. Das kann ich schon gut verstehen, wenn man da keinen Bock drauf hat. Aber Schritt für Schritt wird das schon um sich greifen.
Ja und äh ich meine ist, ich meine beides, also zwei G und drei Gehsen
beide nicht ideal, es ist beides irgendwie Problem behaftet, ja? Bei zweiG hast du halt das das
Problemen natürlich, dass gerade stehen wir jetzt vor so Familien mit Kindern oder so.
Kann dann praktisch äh ja an bestimmter Gastronomie gar nicht teilnehmen äh im Moment. Die sind dann davon oder die wären bei zwei jeder von ausgeschlossen.
Gut, das gilt ja nicht für Kinder. Also es gilt ja sozusagen 2 G gilt ja in dem Sinne, nur für die, die kein Impfangebot haben, wie es so schön heißt.
Naja, was ist dein Moment mehr, aber bei bei zwei G, ja, also Kinder sind dann sind dann sozusagen Natur äh ihm wohnen dann bei.
Nein, nein, die dürfen dann da nach wie vor mit Testung äh.
Aber dann ist es, dann ist ja doch wieder drei G, dann für Kinder. Ne?
Ja, für Kinder ist 3G. Der Rest 2G. Aber gut, das wird in 1tausend Varianten ausgespielt äh werden und äh wie gut die Maßnahmen dann im Einzelnen auch durchgezogen werden, das stehen nochmal aufm anderen Blatt.
Ja, also ja, schön ist es dann jedenfalls nicht, wenn man dadurch zu sich dann auch Gruppen oder so, dann noch auseinander äh reist. Weil im Moment ist er auch noch,
so das mit dem Impfangebot.
Sagen, ja, jeder hätte es äh jeder hätte glaube ich jetzt erst geimpft sein können, aber sagen
komplett durchgeimpft, denke ich mal. Ähm so müsste man den Leuten noch einen Monat Zeit lassen ungefähr ähm.
Ja gut, es ist im Prinzip auch. Also der Beschluss ist vom 11. August und ab 11. Oktober gilt das also zwei Monate muss reichen.
Also ich ich glaube grundsätzlich ja äh ist das jetzt nicht so schlimm, wie andere Fehlentscheidungen, äh die getroffen wurden.
So in anderen Phasen der der Pandemie.
Der besseren Fehlentscheidung.
Ja, also äh man kann, ja, besser wär's natürlich wie.
Die Leute erst durchzuimpfen und aber ja, was, was, was willst du tun? Ähm man könnte natürlich die Leute klar.
Sagen, okay, Impfzwang oder so äh wäre natürlich auch noch eine Variante A, den's ja in bestimmten Bereichen auch gibt, aber ich.
Denke mal, so wie es sich jetzt darstellt, die Situation wird man wahrscheinlich ohne äh äh hinkommen.
Wahrscheinlich.
Würde einen Impfzwang Menschenleben retten in größerer äh Zahl, könnte ich mir vorstellen, aber ja äh führt dann halt zu.
Anderen äh Problemen, ja und ähm.
Will man auch nicht haben.
Die man ja also wenn wenn's ohne geht, sagen wir so, also so einen Impfzwang sollte dann wirklich eher äh das einen eine ultimar Ratio sein und äh
Ist dann nunmal leider so, dass dann wahrscheinlich äh ja zwischen den Impfzwang wahrscheinlich ein paar tausend
Menschenleben gerettet werden könnten, aber ähm so ist das dann nun mal in der freiheitlichen äh
Gesellschaft, der der Punkt ist halt dann äh ich sehe hm sagen.
Inwieweit es Leute gibt, die.
Dann sage mal, unschuldig in äh äh oder in unvermeidbare Probleme äh,
hinein geraten, wie es in früheren Phasen der der Pandemie war mit manchen Regelungen, wo dann Leute,
waren oder Eltern gezwungen waren, dann unter bestimmten Bedingungen dann trotzdem ihre Kinder ähm.
In die Schule äh zu schicken äh oder so. Und ja äh und
jetzt natürlich ist es ein bisschen übersichtlich gerade, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ähm,
Wer die Leidtragenden oder wer wer besonders äh jetzt Leidtragen möglicherweise sein könnte bei den Regelungen, äh die jetzt kommen, sicherlich eine Gruppe sind halt die Kinder, die jetzt noch nicht geimpft.
Werden können, dass es definitiv noch ein,
Problem an dieser ganzen Strategie, ja, wo man eigentlich auch sagen könnte, hm äh auf der anderen Seite wissen eben auch, dass äh ja, bei den äh Kindern äh dann,
also ungeimpfte Kinder, dann aber etwa so gefährdet sind wie, ich sage mal, geimpfte Fünfzigjährige, ah.
Und von daher kann man das dann vielleicht schon,
auch wenn's wenn's nicht nicht schön ist und manche Leute dann vielleicht auch besonders belastet werden und das auch da einzelne Opfer äh geben,
wird. Ähm ja, es ist dann aber unter dem Strich äh so wie's wie's läuft, dann wahrscheinlich das praktikabelste.
Äh rauscht hier gerade noch. Eine Neuigkeit äh rein, die noch dazu passt in Berlin ist nämlich tatsächlich zwei Gehregelungen für Clubs eingeführt worden jetzt.
Und ab diesem Samstag soll das wohl schon gelten, Zutritt nur für Geimpfte und Genesene, so negativer Coronatest, der Gäste reicht nicht.
Und das ist äh heute beschlossen worden in der Infektionsschutzmaßnahmenverordnung. Ein schönes, langes, deutsches Wort.
Ja, das bedeutet, in Innenräumen der Clubs müssen keine Masken getragen werden. Das ist im Prinzip das Wiedereinsetzen der der Klubkultur wird.
Ja, wird zu Partys führen. Ähm und ich denke, bevor jetzt wieder so ein Aufschrei kommt.
Das war ja auch immer sehr beliebt, ne? Ein beliebtes Partyziel, so dieses äh Jahr hier, die Partyleute, die die immer alles irgendwie äh alle Maßnahmen nach unten reißen.
Muss ich an der Stelle mal klar machen, dass es wirklich der mit am härtesten Betroffene Bereich überhaupt. Also kaum irgendwas ist so ausgeblutet worden wie dieser ganze Veranstaltungsbereich. Ja und wir sind halt jetzt im.
Äh in der Phase der Selbstverantwortung jetzt angekommen. Das kann man, glaube ich, mal so festhalten. Aber bevor wir da noch weiter drauf rumreiten und über Maßnahmen schwadronieren.
Lass uns äh den Blog abschließen und ähm zum Abschluss.
Nochmal einen Artikel aufgreifen, der ein bisschen zurückblickt
Du hast ihn ja auch äh gelesen, ne, wenn ich das richtig sehe, äh ist erschienen schon vor einiger Zeit, schon im Juni tatsächlich äh auf Republik Punkt äh CH
und ähm da geht es ähm darum,
über die Forschung oder sagen wir mal die Annahmen der Medizin insgesamt über Aerosole.
Und ich erinnere mich noch ganz gut, dass das bei uns ja hier am Anfang auch so ein Thema war, ne? Also Covid-9zehn, was ist das eigentlich? Dieses Virus, wie verbreitet es sich? Und als, ich meine, wir leben ja heute noch mit diesen.
Im Supermarkt hast du halt da Schlange da, deine Linien auf dem Boden irgendwie, jetzt musst du irgendwie anderthalb Meter Abstand halten. Das Ding ist irgendwie durch. Also das, das, das, das, das hat sich jetzt irgendwie gezeigt. Und ähm ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, wir hatten relativ früh schon,
ähm unserer Überzeugung geäußert, dass äh Aerosol-Übertragung hier wohl ein stärkeres äh Thema ist.
Genau, ich, ich, genau, ich kann mich.
Erinnern, dass wir äh ja hatten da auch die entsprechenden, ja, Studien äh,
und die offizielle Meinung war aber ganz klar nie ist nicht durch Aerosole übertragen und wir hatten uns dann aber
aufgrund eben verschiedener Vorfälle, unter anderem ein Kreuzfahrtschiff und so war halt
relativ klar, äh dass bestimmte superspredding Events nur erklärbar sind, wenn das Virus
Airborn ist. Und äh sodass wir damals, ja Merz, April oder so
schon an dem an dem Punkt waren wo wir gesagt haben unter bestimmten Bedingungen muss es so sein, vielleicht ist das eine Kombination dann auch aus äh Luftfeuchtigkeit und Temperatur und
anderen äh physiologischen Faktoren, die dann dafür sorgt, dass halt so kleine ähm,
entstehen. Äh das äh ja, dass es halt doch eben übertragen wird, ja.
Aber trotzdem war es halt die WHO, die am Anfang diese Deutung, dass äh es sich bei SARS-CoV2ähm ein Virus äh handelt, der Airborn ist.
Nicht so richtig eingelassen hat. Und der Grund dafür war die Annahme in der Medizin.
Ähm dass alle Viren oder alle Partikel, die größer als fünf Mikrometer sind.
Sein können. Und dieser Artikel in Republik CH handelt von einer.
Forscherin namens Linsemar.
Äh die allerdings nicht im medizinischen Bereich arbeitet, sondern die eher aus so einer Ingenieurstechnischen äh Perspektive auf Aerosole blickt. So und das ist.
Atmosphärenphysikerin.
Genau, Atmosphäre, äh Physikerin, nennt man das dann und äh die setzt sich quasi aus äh ja aus aus technischen Zwängen heraus sozusagen, mit diesem Thema auseinander. Und.
Dir hat sich irgendwie an dieser Feststellung, dass alles, was irgendwie größer als fünf Mikrometer groß ist, dass es nicht Erborn ist, gestoßen und hat sich das dann mal.
Ganz genau,
angeschaut. Und ist dann wirklich mal auch in diese Wissenschaftshistorie äh zurückgegangen und hat mal geforscht, ja wo kommt denn das eigentlich alles her? So, ne? Und hat dann.
In diesem Rahmen festgestellt, dass es sich hier offenbar um eine tradierte Information handelt, die allerdings.
Fehlerhaft ist. Und ähm diese Auseinandersetzung mit der Medizin.
Aus ihrer Perspektive, ja, dass es ihrer Meinung nach so nicht äh sein kann. Äh läuft wohl auch schon seit zehn Jahren. Also zweitausendelf,
sie da erste Vorstöße äh gemacht und versucht so wie diese medizinische Community darauf hinzuweisen, dass ihre Auffassung nach das hier einfach so nicht stimmt.
Aber die medizinische Community hat ihre Einstellung dazu nicht ähm ähm ja nicht geändert, bis vielleicht äh jetzt so, ne? Und wo kommt das jetzt eigentlich her? Also diese fünf Mikrometer beziehen sich ähm.
In einer Studie. Äh das habe ich gar nicht geguckt, von wann äh diese Studie eigentlich äh ist.
Weil die liegt schon ein bisschen länger zurück, ne? Und guck mal kurz.
Dreißiger, 40er Jahre.
50, genau, von von 1955 ist das.
Ähm eine Studie, die sich ausschließlich auf Tubakulose und deren Übertragbarkeit in die Lunge,
beschäftigt hat. Ja? Also es ist keine allgemeine Annahme über,
was ist eine Aerosol und an wann wann beginnt etwas irgendwie zu sein, sondern es ist ausschließlich eine Zahl
die sich eben aus dieser Analyse äh konkret auf äh Tuberkulose Infektion und die Übertragbarkeit in die Lunge, also sozusagen äh,
erst dort kann Tuberkulose ja Schaden anrichten, äh der Covid-Neunzehnäh alles angreift, ne und,
Und diese Zahl aus dieser alten Studie wurde einfach übernommen und ist so über die Zeit so als generelle, maximale Größe,
oder minimale Größe ähm festgesetzt worden so, ne? Und
ja ähm setzt sich das irgendwie mit einer Wissenschaftshistorikerin,
zusammengetan und und dann haben die sich also wirklich durch diese alten Studien mehrerer Forscher durchgearbeitet
und haben dann äh quasi nachgewiesen, dass es sich sozusagen bei dieser Information um ein um ein ein Missverständnis einfach handelt, weil einfach hier quasi die falschen äh äh Dinge äh sozusagen
herausgezogen worden und als als Beleg genommen wurden.
Ja und äh mittlerweile, also jetzt hat es wohl auch die CDC in USA eingesehen, dass also auch größere Partikel.
Nämlich bis zu 100 Mikrometer groß, durchaus Aerogen sein können.
Das ist natürlich schon mal ein riesiger Unterschied, ne.
Und daraus und um's kurz abzuschließen und daraus leitet sich in gewisser Hinsicht auch ab, dass diese ganze Thematik der Tröpfcheninfektion.
Gar nicht so,
das hohe Thema ist, ne? Was was haben wir am Anfang überall Händewaschen diskutiert und was nicht alles und irgendwie kommen wir nicht zu nah und anderthalb Meter Abstand halten, aber Tröpfcheninfektionen
scheint also generell gar nicht so sehr äh das Problem zu sein, sondern diese äh areosole und diese Aerogene Übertragung ist wahrscheinlich schon so, dass das Kern äh Problem. Und jetzt im April 21 hat die CDU,
das jetzt auch eingesehen und Ario Sohle gelten jetzt generell als die wichtigste Übertragung von Viren, ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie jetzt nur auf SARS-CoV2 Bezug oder generell
Ja und damit wissen wir eigentlich, dass diese ganzen zwei Meter Abstandsregelungen oder anderthalb Meter Abstandsregelungen eigentlich Unfug sind und so überhaupt keinen Bestand mehr haben müssten.
Ne?
Also eine sehr interessante Story, kann ich euch sehr empfehlen. Das nochmal nachzulesen. Man kann auf jeden Fall daraus ziehen. Erstens.
Erkenntnisse können sich auch ändern.
Bestimmte Dinge, die schon immer so waren, können sich dann auch mal äh ändern und es dauert äh manchmal auch zehn Jahre, bis man so einen kollektiven Prozess.
Der so bei allen so stattfindet und so so ein ich weiß nicht so ein etabliertes Wissen dann auch überrollt, aber es ist auf der anderen Seite auch möglich.
Das äh finde ich ja auch ganz positiv.
Wobei ich noch sagen würde, ich denke mal schon, dass Abstand hilft.
Ja ja klar.
Nur äh was äh also es gibt jetzt keinen Grund irgendwie, warum ein bestimmter Abstand äh so,
ausreichend oder also jedenfalls die einen anderthalb oder zwei Meter oder so dürften eben in vielen Fällen einfach schlichtweg.
Nicht ausreichend äh gewesen sein, aber geholfen hat's wahrscheinlich, glaube ich, trotzdem irgendwie mehr Abstand zu halten.
Ja, also mehr Abstand zu halten hilft. Nur es ist jetzt nicht so, dass jetzt wenn man anderthalb Meter Abstand hält, auf einmal alles irgendwie gut ist, sondern es hängt einfach
von der Temperatur ab, es hängt von dem Wind ab, es hängt von der Umgebung ab, es hängt äh von der Luftfeuchtigkeit ab, es hängt von all diesen von der UV-Strahlung hängt es ab,
diese Dinge und man muss so ein bisschen so ein Gefühl dafür gewinnen, das ist natürlich schwierig, aber vielleicht haben wir das jetzt auch alle gelernt. Okay, was ist eine unangenehme Situation? Und ich mache bei mir schon so ein
so ein Alarmsystem äh nämlich wahr. Was ich mir jetzt so erlernt habe, so dieses.
Mit wem bist du da? Wo bist du, ne? Wie windig ist es jetzt gerade? Ich habe überhaupt gar kein Problem mit Leuten zusammen zu stehen, ohne Maske draußen und es ist irgendwie viel
viel Wind und äh pipapo, da sagt mir halt mein System, es muss nicht unbedingt richtig liegen, aber mein System sagt mir das so. Ja okay, passt schon, so, ne? Kaum, dass ich nach innen gehe und irgendwie mit Leuten zusammen bin, die ich auch nicht kenne.
Ja, also nicht, dass jetzt
Mein Kennenlernstatus für die Infektion in irgendeiner Form relevant wäre, aber ähm da spielt ja auch mit rein. So dieses Visier kann ich den Leuten vertrauen, was, was, was, was, was haben die sozusagen für Testzyklen und und und wie verhalten diese anderen Leuten gegenüber? Nichts davon würde.
Irgendwas äh nachhaltig verändern, verhindern können, aber das äh trägt natürlich alles dazu bei.
Ja, wobei ich hm tatsächlich auch gestehen muss, ich fahr.
Neulich tatsächlich das erste Mal abends äh in einem Innenraum äh in einer Bar trinken. Mhm. Ohne Maske.
Oha, aber du kannst es alle. Auch nicht.
Nee, nee. Aber äh ja.
Pavel, was ist los? Wirfst du jetzt alle? Alle Vorsicht fort.
Ja äh nee, ich werde das sicherlich nicht zur Regel äh äh werden lassen, aber äh ja, es war irgendwie kalt draußen und es hat geregnet und äh ja ähm.
So fängt's an.
Ja, nee, ich kann's verstehen. Ich meine, diese dieser äh äh Druck zur äh Normalität, jetzt habe ich das Wort schon wieder gesagt, der ist groß und ich glaube, der wird in diesem Herbst, in diesem Winter überhandnehmen.
Also einfach, ich glaube, wir sind jetzt an die Grenze der Belastbarkeit in der Hinsicht gekommen und die Leute tauschen.
Ähm das das eine Risiko gegen ein anderes Risiko ein.
Ja, das Risiko weiter äh zu vereinsamen, das Risiko weiterhin keine äh sozialen äh Bindungen der Geschwindigkeit zu pflegen oder neu aufzunehmen, wie man das bisher äh gewohnt war
erscheint vielen Leuten dann größer. Man kann halt dann nur eben sagen, minimiert dann bitte das andere Risiko auch mit den Möglichkeiten.
Die jetzt bestehen und die bestehen und die sollte man dann halt auch äh entsprechend machen. Ansonsten bin ich aber auch trotzdem äh sehr für eine Dritteimpfung äh empfänglich, muss ich sagen. Äh Israel, ich habe das vorhin schon erwähnt, hat ja
ähm.
Jetzt quasi auch die die also man gilt jetzt in Israel nicht mehr als vollständig geimpft, wenn man nicht die Drittempfung hat.
Das heißt quasi von heute auf morgen sind ganz viele Leute gelten auf einmal wieder als ungeimpft. Und ich habe jetzt auch nochmal hier die Zahlen äh nachgeschlagen.
Ähm leider habe ich jetzt keine Gesamtzahl, aber ich habe sie so nach Altersgruppe, aber das ist auch schon sehr interessant.
Bei den siebzig bis äh neunzig plus, also so siebzig plus äh liegt die äh Verimpfungsquote bei sagenhaften, na ja ich sage mal so fünfundsiebzig Prozent im Schnitt.
Also 75 Prozent von 70 plus hat die dritte Impfung erhalten in Israel.
Und äh dann geht es ja immer, wie sich das gehört hier in zehn Jahres äh Schritten nach unten, äh sechsundsechzig Prozent bei 60 plus.
50 Prozent, bei 50 plus 32 Prozent bei 40 Plus.
Also dann vierzig plus, also vierzig bis bis bis neunundvierzig, ne, also immer Zehnjahresblöcke. Äh und dann, wie zu erwarten war bei den Jüngeren, sind die äh entsprechenden,
Impfungs-, Drittimpfungszahlen niedriger, was jetzt bei 20bis 29 nicht überrascht, weil wie vorhin schon erwähnt, 30 Plus angesagt.
Worauf ich hinaus will ist, Dritte im Fond, ich bin dabei, also nehme ich sofort. Ich dachte mir auch, ähm.
Ich mache mir jetzt so eine so eine Impfsammelkarte. Collectom all. Ja, ich will, will mit mit allem mal geimpft worden sein.
Ja, also jetzt äh wäre ich erstmal für äh noch einen Schuss moderner äh zu haben.
Grad jetzt wohl nochmal so eine Studie rauskam, die gesagt hat, moderner ist ja sogar noch effizienter als Biotech, das war irgendwie eine äh Untersuchung in Belgien,
denke ich mir so, okay, alles klar, wenn das, wenn das Zeug so gut ist, dann dann hätte ich da ganz gerne nochmal einen von so. Ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich gerade eh genug so, ja, ich frage mich, warum darf man sich jetzt eigentlich nicht dritt impfen lassen?
Israel schon irgendwie fünfundsiebzig Prozent der alten äh äh das dritte Mal verimpft hat, ja, wo warum, also ich zahle auch gern für.
Ach so. Ich übernehme auch gerne die Kosten, aber ich äh hätte halt einfach gerne so die äh Gelegenheit und ich würd's mir vor allem auch gerne
gerne ähm dann auch bestätigen lassen. Also ich will jetzt hier nicht so eine Offline-Level Impfung machen. Denn wenn man jetzt
nach Israel will, muss man ja geimpft sein, damit man keine Quarantäne hat.
Und wenn die halt nur akzeptieren Drittimpfung ist eine richtige Impfung, ist die einzige Möglichkeit, da hinzureisen, quasi noch eine dritte Impfung.
Also her damit. Ich nehme äh an, ich nehme Angebote entgegen, äh die bekannten euch äh bekannten Kanäle.
Brasilien gab's ja auch noch eine Geschichte, wo sich irgendjemand ich weiß nicht sechs oder acht Impfungen erschlichen.
So der sie immer dann unter falschem Namen irgendwie neu.
Sammelkarte.
Ja, ja. Und der, der wollt's irgendwie richtig wissen. Er meinte, okay, wenn eine Impfung gut ist, dann können fünf oder sechs Impfungen einfach nur besser sein und ja, mhm.
Und er lebt noch.
Ja ja, der hatte jetzt keine Probleme mehr mit, außer dass natürlich in einem Land, äh wo Impfstoffe nach wie vor knapp sind, äh so äh die Behörden das nicht so lustig fanden.
Der.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, bei uns gehen die Impfstoffe mittlerweile an andere Länder, das ist auch gut, ja, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall jetzt kein, kein, kein Mangel. Es sind auch noch viele bestellt. Und ähm ich sehe da jetzt nicht so ein großes Problem dadrin. Äh Leuten, die das wollen, auch eine Drittimpfung.
Haben wir im Prinzip ja auch schon, also es ist ja gilt ja jetzt schon äh ich glaube für.
Sechzig plus, glaube ich, ne. Ähm und für Leute mit ähm besonderen Erkrankungen wird, glaube ich, schon dritte Impfung auch angeboten.
Um das aufzufrischen, beziehungsweise nochmal einen extra Schutz zu machen und nach allem, was man weiß, ähm hilft es auch entsprechend. Das ist auch eine gute Nachricht
Einfach regelmäßige Auffrischung können äh dazu führen, dass der Schutz noch besser wird
und ähm ja, also falls ihr nach Pionieren und äh risikofreuden, risikofreudigen Leuten schaut, die äh Drittempfung ausprobieren wollten,
Hier der Daumen ist oben.
Ja, ich.
Würde nur denken, dass man schon, ich sage mal, nach der zweiten Impfung, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht schon, ein paar Monate einfach.
Warten kann auch äh so also ich ich denke mal, so dass normalerweise, also die ersten drei Monate müssten eigentlich die neutralisierenden
Antikörper, wenn welche da sind, ganz gut sein, wenn nicht, bin natürlich nicht so viele äh da sind, ja, kann's man eigentlich müsste man.
Das halt irgendwie messen vorher. Hier müssten wir halt gucken, wie sieht's denn aus so mit äh neutralisierenden Antikörpern und abhängig davon.
Dann äh ja das Ganze machen, ja.
Ja gut, also ich meine, ich habe jetzt irgendwie meine letzte Impfung, äh wann hatte ich meine Zweitimpfung? Meine Zweitimpfung war Ende. Äh Juli, August ist rum.
Das ist schon zwei Monate.
Also Paar Monate sind schon rum. Ein paar. Ehrlich gesagt, ich will das ja nur machen, damit ich auch mal äh diese tollen Impfreaktionen äh spüre, von denen immer alle erzählen, weil ich hatte ja davon überhaupt nix.
Und der ganze Spaß ist an mir vorbeigegangen. Uns mal sehen, das sind die Leiden. Die Leiden des jungen.
Äh ja, ist vielleicht doch noch eine Sache, ja, zu dritt Impfung kam dann äh ja quasi auch mal jetzt wieder die äh
Neid, Luxus oder Verteilungsdebatte auf, dass wir uns auch nicht ernsthafterweise drittimpfen lassen können, wo doch ein Großteil der Welt noch nicht mal eine eine Erstimpfung hat. Äh
so. Ähm.
Ja. Insofern, ich meine, es ist sicherlich auch äh einen einen Punkt, so,
ähm ja auf der anderen Seite habe ich jetzt gerade nicht das Gefühl, dass äh im Moment äh wirklich jemand.
In Entwicklungsländern einen Impfstoff kriegt, weil hier Leute auf äh eventuell Drittimpfungen verzichten,
und früher oder später immer ist ja jetzt auch keine Überraschung
so, dass das irgendwann losgeht, sondern eigentlich reden wir ja schon vor einem halben Jahr darüber, dass man irgendwann nach spätestens sechs Monaten eigentlich nochmal auffrischen müsste und gerade in den Gesundheitsberufen jetzt die Leute äh
ja, wäre vielleicht nicht verkehrt. Ich meine, andere Sache noch, äh die mir durch den Kopf gegangen ist, was.
Mir nicht ganz klar ist, aber was möglicherweise natürlich auch äh äh bei einer Immunisierung helfen kann, ist, wenn man als Geimpfter sich dann halt infiziert und einen leichten Verlauf hat.
So, nicht, dass ich dazu jemandem raten würde, das zu tun.
Aber äh es ist halt auch ein Effekt. Auf der anderen Seite kann man natürlich, wenn man sich als Geimpfter infiziert und der Immunstatus nicht so hoch ist, kann's natürlich sein, dass man dann
wie äh ja Varianten ausbrütet, die äh den Impfschutz äh besonders gut äh umgehen. Es wäre vielleicht auch nochmal ein Grund, warum
man die Leute dritt äh impfen sollte, weil das äh,
einfach der Variantenentstehung vorbeugen dürfte.
Ja, das sind ähm das kann man sich dann bloß nicht dokumentieren lassen. Also ich denke nicht, dass das als als äh normale Dritteimpfung anerkannt wird.
Ne? Äh und und immer diese formale Anerkennung finde ich jetzt auch nicht so unwichtig. Weil das ist ja dann wiederum genau das.
Dann der Schlüssel ist zu dem in Anführungsstrichen normalen Leben. Ja, also gut, Israelreise ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen weit hergeholt, aber das wird nicht das einzige Beispiel bleiben, sondern dieser Zustand wird kommen.
Wir wir werden Beschränkungen haben, so wie wir sie jetzt auf vollständige Impfungen haben, wird eben diese Zusatzimpfung, zumindest im Falle von Biontech, wie das dann mit,
JJ und so weiter ist, weiß ich noch nicht ganz genau, wobei da gibt's jetzt auch schon erste Ergebnisse, dass eine Zweitimpfung mit Johnson und Johnson auch eine sehr gute Idee.
Was so den Impfschutz betrifft? Also wir werden diese verstärkenden Maßnahmen auch ohnehin äh bekommen. So und äh sie sind halt.
In Israel jetzt grade schon gültig. Ja und äh von daher hätte ich ja dann auch ganz gerne dafür dann noch den passenden Schlüssel.
So bin ich.
Ja. Bin.
Gespannt, ob die ganze Technik das äh schon kann, ob die schon drauf vorbereitet ist. Und wie gesagt, die andere, was du meintest, äh eine Kombination äh äh genesen und geimpft äh
Meinst du nicht, wenn du wenn du einen positiven Test hast, ist egal, ob du dann erst geimpft und dann genesen bist oder erst genesen und dann äh zu sagen, nachgeimpft sollte eigentlich ja kein Unterschied machen, im Gegenteil, denke ich mal.
In der medizinischen Wirkung jetzt oder in der äh in in der ähm grenzdeklaration in Israel.
Sowohl in der Wirkung als auch äh äh denke ich, sollte das eigentlich Nachweistechnisch auch entsprechend äh äh gleich behandelt werden.
Ja gut, aber das muss dann irgendwie von alleine passieren. Dann äh würde ich mich dann doch lieber offiziell impfen lassen.
Ja, gut, aber äh ich denke soweit sind wir erstmal äh durch, ja.
Genau. Leute, wir ähm reduzieren jetzt so langsam hier ähm die.
Also wir erhöhen die Frequenz und wir reduzieren die Abstände zwischen den Sendungen. Äh ganz auf Weekly sind wir noch nicht, aber wir wollen auch wieder so ein bisschen
in die Spur kommen, weil ich denke jetzt grade in der nächsten Zeit wird es wieder ganz interessant sein, äh zu verfolgen, wie sich die Inzidenzen und die ganzen anderen Rahmenparameter
so verhalten und entwickeln und ja und auch den einzelnen News geschehen,
da besser folgen zu können ist Eis und Wochenabstand ganz praktisch, weil sonst legt man sich immer so links beiseite und denkt sich dann irgendwann so wieder
ist das jetzt überhaupt noch aktuell. Da muss man dann irgendwie im Wochenabstand nicht so drüber nachdenken.
Ja, also wir werden dann immer immer mehr Weekly. Bis dahin wünschen wir euch natürlich noch eine angenehme und äh infektionsfreie Zeit.
Und ähm wie gesagt, wer noch nicht geimpft ist von euch, ab ab ins Impfzentrum.
Aber ganz schnell.
Ja oder zum Hausarzt.
Oder zum Hausarzt, genau. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Ach so, mach mal noch Clubhausrunde nächste Woche, machen wir wieder, oder?
Ich würde mal sagen, nächsten äh nächsten Dienstag, dann äh sind wir auch wieder auf dem dienstags ähm Termin. Machen wir einfach noch mal eine Runde bei äh Clubhaus. Da findet ihr uns dann äh auch.
Auf Twitter werden wir das auch nochmal ankündigen. Ich packe das auch in die. Ja und dann ähm könnt ihr auch mit uns quatschen und nochmal ein paar Sachen hinterfragen.
So, das war's jetzt aber auch.
Tschüss.